foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
check check check my check my check one
two
because you guys just love this music
don't you guys just follow this music
this is there a Ravenclaw one playing
right now if you've already listened to
it multiple times and you you probably
already know
foreign
you probably already know
welcome welcome everyone
[Music]
sorry I'm a little a little bit late
tonight not too bad I guess technically
we went live right around eight but
normally I try and have the countdown
finished by eight
but we um my kids are getting really
into Mario 3D World
and we only have three controllers so we
didn't know if the GameCube one would
work so we tested it and it worked so we
got my wife playing tonight oh they
thought that was so funny
they thought it was so funny so we had a
little uh little extra time of us just
playing and hanging out dude we already
got some uh
before we even started streaming hold up
hold up looks like some people renewed
their membership even before we got
started tonight
let's see Dylan renewed his membership
earlier tonight so did Ravenclaw okay
hold on guys I love the music but I
gotta turn it down a wee bit
actually I can just turn it down here
for you guys that way
[Music]
all right turn it down right here how
are you welcome turn it back up over
here so yeah it looks like Dylan
Ravenclaw Tyrell Danny David how are you
wait did all these just all these
renewed before the stream tonight I
don't know if that's correct or not but
whether or not it's correct David hayeku
Warrior and Elwyn uh welcome back to
house rack and tour my friends thank you
for continuing to be a member here and
then we had Dylan with the ten dollar
Super Chat smash that like button have a
great stream hashtag replay Squad Dylan
dude as always thank you for the support
guys Dylan a member of House wreck and
tour also a moderator here uh his
schedule right now unfortunately
prevents him from hanging out too long
for each stream but definitely a big
time member of the stream Big Time
member of our community here and he's uh
he's also over on the Discord but uh
he uh he has some things going on work
related things that prevent him from
being able to always
attend the streams but it's all good all
good
all right I need to uh got too much
Headroom here let me fix the camera real
quick so congrats if you just got a gift
membership there from Dylan
and then or no Dylan didn't gift
memberships Elwyn gifted memberships L
one gifted five memberships so welcome
Johnny the hustle puff Russell got one
of the gifteds showed a chat showed it
so did Shadow guided Tiffy land Bristol
boy JP raven fire welcome to house
tracking tour everyone elwin thank you
for the gift memberships guys uh when
you're a member of House Dragon tour you
get access to all the fun little
Wizarding World related emoji that we
have here in the chat
how are you also get discounts on merch
in our merch store
uh you can go to retrorackintour.com to
get to that
um but yeah if you're looking for all
the benefits of being a member you just
go to the YouTube Community page and
you'll find it there so L1 thank you so
much for the support uh then we had
let's see Casey with the two dollar
Super Chat GameCube is the best oh yeah
you can't see it as well right now my
still to this day one of my favorite
controllers of all time the wave bird
GameCube is just such a comfortable
controller so comfortable
I don't know why Nintendo ever went away
from that design but I love I do love
the uh the Pro controller for the switch
as well I wasn't a fan of the Wii the
Wii U controllers even the Pro
Controller wasn't a fan of those but the
with the switch they got it right it's
pretty durable controller
then we had Ravenclaw Tyrell with the
five gifted memberships Ravenclaw Tyrell
how's it going thank you for the gifted
memberships so wolfy Professor Baxter
zodiac go ninja go and Martin all just
became members of house Dragon tour
thanks to Ravenclaw Tyrell
thank you so much for the gifted
memberships
and then Dustin with the five dollar
Super Chat in before the gifted
membership memberships with a super chat
because I can't do the memberships on
mobile
I I hear that a lot of people have
trouble with the I've actually never
tried it for mobile
I don't I don't know if it's possible I
don't know I don't know if anyone in the
chat can help you out but regardless
thank you for the Super Chat Dustin good
to see you here hanging out
and then we also had let's see
do we have a couple more uh Shadow Jago
boss hyper curse bark Lee all three of
those I don't know if those were gifteds
or those might have been or those okay
some of those were gifted some of those
weren't gifted regardless guys thank you
for uh becoming members of house Dragon
tour here it's not gifts are on PC only
gotcha thank you Owen then Noob also
gifting five tier one memberships Noob
thank you so much my friend so Noob uh
gifted memberships to curse Barkley
Jonathan Bradley Jay Rossi J Rossi in
the house what's up my friend congrats
on another gift and membership and then
Jason Hodges another name I recognize as
well guys congratulations and welcome to
house wrecking tour where we are
currently developing a coat of arms a
house motto if you will
but uh thank you all so much and then we
had let's see gav
bean bean town
Emily
all three of those just subscribe to the
channel so so thank you for subscribing
and then jaybirds renewing their
membership Jay birds thank you so much
another member of House wreck and tour
uh I see little picket in the chat
renewing their membership happy
Christmas indeed I wish we said happy
Christmas I love the phrase happy
Christmas Happy Christmas here in the US
it's always Merry Christmas so
and I was I was going back and reading I
was looking back in Sorcerer's Stone
because of course in the movies they say
happy Christmas but in the books in the
US versions they actually it changed it
to Merry Christmas in the in the first
book
Shadow guided a member for three months
nice let's go Shadow guided we all love
retro reckon tour hey I love you guys
too that's why oh Shadow guided dude
you're setting up the perfect segue
that's why we're gonna have a very
special live stream this Friday I know
Friday's not our usual day but we put it
to a vote over a thousand of you voted
by the way a thousand of you thank you
guys so much
um but it is our big celebration stream
so
as I have watched a lot of streamers and
YouTubers one of my favorite things is
always when I see the ones give back to
the community you know and frankly just
to be honest with you I've never been in
a great position to do that uh Nico will
tell you when I was on Twitch for a
while we did a couple of like little
giveaways there but nothing compared to
what we're gonna be doing this Friday
um over 500 if you add up all the prizes
so we're gonna have lots of winners
because I split it up a little bit the
three whoa I'm getting ahead of myself
we're gonna go over here in a second
we're gonna go over here in just a
moment D Jane with a super chat as well
wanted to show my thanks for bringing us
all amazing content and continuing to
keep us hyped for the game you do
amazing retro thank you djane thank you
so much for the compliment and I mean it
wouldn't be possible without you guys
would not be possible without all of you
and it's exciting man like um just like
before we really get started with the
stream a couple of uh housekeeping
things for those of you who were able to
I saw several of you in the chat last
Friday evening so uh Alex from podcast
now invited several of us to be on for a
just a big big live stream with uh
several other Hogwarts Legacy creators
and it was such a great time it was uh
Alex from podcast now uh James expecto
go we had uh Andy reloads there Benjamin
snow uh Professor Lynette was her PhD
was there as well nightly nerd the last
Marauder lamorrack and
oh there's one more there was one more
let's see I said nightly nerd I said
last Marauder I said uh I said Andy
reloads oh man no
oh wait wait Hogwarts like as he
explained yes yes you guys know most of
them already but it was we had a great
time I saw many of you there in the chat
we ended up going for three hours which
I I didn't think I was gonna have
that much time but man it's just like
it's so motivating I tell you when
you're around other
other creators and other people who are
excited and pumped for this game it was
so fun it was so fun I hope that came
across and I felt bad and poor Andy was
he was so sick Andy was coming down with
the flu and then for the UK friends who
were on it was like 2 A.M by the time we
got done for them so maybe next time
we'll be able to move it up a little bit
earlier and maybe even get some other
Hogwarts Hogwarts creators on too
because I'm I'm noticing as the game
gets closer there are more and more
names popping up I'm getting more and
more recommendations on my front page of
YouTube of like oh here's a Hogwarts
video so but it was a great time so any
of you who were able to be there
appreciate you stopping by and uh
showing support the full VOD is still up
if you if you want to see it but
honestly it was just us answering a
bunch of fan questions talking about
things were hyped for
and just making sure you guys enjoy this
time because yeah it's crazy it's crazy
how close we are it's crazy I mean we
are almost at Christmas here the end of
the year is almost here January the
game's already gone gold at least for
the current Engine Systems anyway
um man I tell you so
I mean we really only have
let's see in terms of our regular
Tuesday streams
we have tonight then we have the 27th
then the third so that's three streams
if you count tonight four five six seven
dude
eight or seven streams
seven streams left
before Hogwarts Legacy
insane just insane man
[Music]
um but yeah that that that whole big
live stream got me got me hyped Eric
thank you for subscribing to the channel
all right let's shout out everybody in
the chat here
let me go and look at participants here
uh we got Adam in the chat ether and
Alicia both members of house wreck and
tour right there Amore poet I have not
seen that name in a while welcome back
I'm Maury poet I hope you're doing well
uh Beantown Brasco Clint curse Barclay
that's member of House wreck and tour uh
dark lord
Aaron welcome David hey David I always
see David uh commenting on the videos
thank you for that David D Jane Dr
sherbet Draco Dustin Quest all members
of house Dragon tour right there thank
you guys for being here hanging out EFA
Spartan Elwyn moderator and also member
of House Dragon tour in-house Eric is
here Gabe and Gigi is a lobster both
members of house tracking tour right
there Hannah uh we got Jake in the house
what's up Jake Jason Hodges uh Jenny I
saw I saw Jenny hanging out in uh
expecto ghost twitch stream today Johnny
the hustlepuff Russell Jonathan and JP
ravenfire
all from Jake all the way down right
there all those members of house Dragon
tour
k7k0 Casey Lawrence Chris Elven puff
Lauren D members of house tracking tour
right there back to back to back we got
Levi Mays we got Logan we got Luca we
got Matt Michael another oh we got two
Michaels now too Michael Sullivan member
pass Dragon tour welcome Michael uh Mike
Moon Lily miles Noob nagura Ravenclaw
Nathan Nico
from Moon Lily all the way down how
striking to our members thank you guys
so much Nico also moderator here uh no
caps
work TV uh welcome Professor Baxter
Psalm Ravenclaw Tyrell
all three members of house Dragon tour
there we got uh sorry
Shadow Jago 1989 shadow guy to members
of house wrecking tour Sharon
solar zinsay
Terrell little the bearded cook love
that name Tiffy land Channel member here
Timothy Gunn turbo Tim games Ultra Blue
Jr Wolfie member of housewrecking tour
wubby is here hanging out expecto go I
don't know if he's been able to chat yet
but uh he is indeed hanging out expect
to go thank you for being here and
Zachariah expect to go member of House
track and tour
there we go guys that's it wizard PhD in
the in the house too with
what is up hope your better
good to see you here hanging out
but yeah I was I was just telling chat
what a great time we had on the uh on
the live stream on Friday
so yeah I don't know like
if something was in the air
in the air virtually because Andy was
sick then I saw Lynette was sick
immediately after that and I think I saw
that Hogwarts Legacy explained was
extinct 2 it was sick too then Lynette
was sick
just like knocking on wood at this point
man I hope and I don't get sick right
before the holidays
Elwyn uh your BC Canada Guild are under
snow no no way it's so cold where I'm at
right now actually it's not too bad
today but by the end of the week it's
supposed to get even colder probably
what you guys are normally used to up
there in Canada
oh man
there's expecto go
last Marauders got sick too James what
oh this is just bizarre
music is a tad loud all right we'll turn
it down just a bit
we'll turn it down just slightly there
[Music]
everyone getting sick in England oh my
goodness yeah right now where I live the
hospitals have been getting pretty uh
slammed lately because it's like RSV and
young kids like the RSV the cold virus
then the flu and then
the uh the other word YouTube doesn't
like you to say
the pandemic related related one
so those are yeah it's been crazy both
my kids were sick over the past few
weeks so hopefully everybody is good to
go now for the holidays fueled by the
fire what is up my friend renewing their
membership welcome to house wrecking
tour
also zenister just subscribe to the
channel
yo Steven rice with the Super Chat
oh man you know I'm on my game if I'm
catching it before it even pops up here
I caught it in the chat dude caught it
in the chat Steven thank you for the
Super Chat I don't see a comment with it
though Steven so thank you so much dude
all right so guys uh I'm gonna switch
over here I'm gonna switch over
how are you
welcome to Gryffindor
[Music]
is this it's like they knew we had a
Christmas celebration stream coming up
dude
they knew like this I would I kid you
not guys I told my moderators this on
Discord I was looking for you know all
over YouTube there are those like
um there's like ASMR channels there's
like channels that are just like Lo-Fi
just music there are channels that like
show different holiday scenes and play
music I was looking for a good scene
that I could have going during our
Christmas celebration I was like I just
want it to be like we're we're just
sitting around a fire you know sharing
stories at at the holidays and uh then
Hogwarts drops these videos I couldn't
believe it
because I was kind of worried I was like
can I show these other like these videos
can I put them on streams that copyright
I don't know
so then when Hogwarts posted these I was
like yes this is perfect this is perfect
oh I hope so little picket I don't know
I almost wonder if they're gonna wait
like if these little
these little common room
fires or the or to like hold us over
I hope we do though after they showed
that that winter scene to bend in the uh
gameplay showcase
I want more
I want more it is Draco it's so perfect
So Perfect all right I'll turn it down
just a tab more I just want to make sure
you guys it's not too loud for you guys
all right so yeah the other thing I
wanted to pull up here
[Music]
so Christmas celebration for those of
you who haven't seen if you follow me on
Twitter or whatever or are in the
Discord you've already seen this but I
want to make sure that everybody knows
about this so first of all expect to go
doing a Yule Ball tomorrow evening
uh wizard PhD was here hanging out and
myself both both of us are giving away
some merch as part of James's thing that
he's doing so if you aren't already
following James expect to go make sure
you're following him check him out
um on his Wizarding Wednesday tomorrow
they're doing a Yule Ball stream and
he's got some giveaways I don't know if
he's announced all the details just yet
um but you know check his socials you
know he's always streaming Wednesday
evening Wednesday afternoon that range
so yeah I'm gonna be giving away
um a merch item for that
in turn James is going to be giving away
a merch item for us so
oh wait we missed hold on hold on we got
a uh
dark lord Aeron renewed their membership
missed that one sorry for that Aeron
thank you so much for uh becoming a
member of House wrecking tour here and
then Noob with the Super Chat retro I
sent your Christmas present on Discord
oh my goodness Noob I'll have to check
that out
but yeah like Noob and several others so
many have reached out like how can we
help with the giveaway no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no this this is my
turn guys it's my turn to get back to
you a little bit
my turn to get back to you
so let's go over this just quick
housekeeping before we get into the you
know this whole Hogwarts Legacy news
thing before we get into all of that
so here here's what's going down this
Friday if you can't make it I'm sorry
that was the date that won we put up a
poll over 50 of it was like
overwhelmingly more than double the
others it was a huge favorite over the
other so that's why I went with Friday
same time 8 P.M it's not going to be as
long of a stream as normal I know you
guys got family you got holiday stuff to
get to so you're not gonna I'm not gonna
make you sit around and wait like three
hours before we get to the giveaways
we're gonna get started pretty quick so
you don't want to be you don't want to
be late
um but we have such a worldwide audience
I've talked to James about this a couple
of the moderators about this I was like
we got to figure out how to do
we got to figure out how to do this so a
worldwide audience can be you know
participate
um I because I loved I'd love to have
bought just like have a bunch of like
presents back here you know like gift
boxes and Wizarding World stuff video
game I would have loved to have done
that
um but we have I I don't think I could
ship worldwide I don't know I've never
tried
so I was like okay we I want to do
something that everybody can at least
participate in one of the giveaways
so we're going to start off with just
some Amazon gift cards that's super easy
if you enter to win the Amazon gift
cards guys you will have to give an
email just to me nobody else will see it
but you will have to give me your email
so
don't even you know Friday that's when
we'll enter there's going to be a word
that we'll Post in the chat that's how
you you'll enter it
but um yeah so if you're under 18 guys
if you're under 18
please check with your parents
check with your parents or Guardian
first to make sure
they're okay with this
um so for the merch so I'm going to be
giving away three of my merch items of
your choice anything in the Retro rack
into our shop you can pick same thing
for expecto go he's going to be giving
away one item from his shop pick
anything there
same thing if you're now for that one
though you we will need a physical
address again only I will see it in the
case of my merch and then if you win one
of James's merch items he'll have to see
it of course and that's it so
if you're not over 18 check with a
parent
um so they know what's going on here
show them the stream if you want to
enter it doesn't have to be your address
it could be you know it doesn't have to
be your name
so you can actually put like if you just
want to do initials or something I know
I
it's always weird like given your name
online trust me I get it so if you're
not comfortable that totally cool
um but just you know if you can't just
don't enter for because for the merch
items we will need a physical address
for that then I will give away a God no
it's not us only Wolfie not us only so
for the merch the great thing about the
merch items through uh it's through the
Teespring store basically I will just go
on and buy it for you but I will put in
your address
and they they ship worldwide I double
checked on that which is nice so
yeah same thing for the Amazon gift
cards I mean as long as you have Amazon
in your country all you all I need is
your email and it'll send you the gift
card 25 US dollars I hope Amazon will
convert
hope it will convert
and then here's the one that I'm not 100
sure on God of War Ragnarok
I have a digital code for God of War
Ragnarok the one that came with my
collector's edition which was purchased
in the US it doesn't say anything on
there about the region lock and I'll
tell you guys all this again before the
giveaway on Friday I just want to make
sure we're up front with everyone
but um so that one you know it is for
PS4 or PS5
PS4 or PS5 doesn't say anything about
region locking
um but I I just bought it in the US so
just know that going in then the big one
the big one the fun one and this one is
the one that said the most questions
because I put up PS5 pictures
so I'll be giving away three copies of
Hogwarts Legacy digital Deluxe No I
don't have early copies when the game
comes out
and it's the platform of your choice you
can pick the platform
so it does not have to be PS5 it will
not be a physical copy it will be a
digital copy
um XBox Steam and I'm pretty sure epic
as well have pretty easy gifting options
so if it's one of those platforms I
think I'll just need like your email I
think is all I will need if it's
PlayStation we'll have to kind of we'll
have to do it through like the
PlayStation Store like a gift card like
that instead and if you decide you don't
you want to use it for something else
fine you know whatever
if you win an item and you don't need it
guys feel free to pass it along and gift
it
um because I I mean
I we we did this before when I did a
small twitch giveaway
we did away uh we did away we gave away
25 Amazon card and we started having
people in the chat saying I I don't need
it I don't need it like trying to give
it back
because they were they were trying to
give it to other members of the
community
that's like that's the kind of community
I'm trying to build which is awesome but
you guys keep it you keep it if you
decide you want to re-gift it to someone
else that's great you know that's great
but once you win it's going to you okay
so recap emails will be needed for the
Amazon cards for the digital copies of
this and for the digital copies of this
I will need I'm assuming all I will need
is an email for those if you win uh the
merch we will need a physical address so
Friday night the way it'll work there
will be like a word for each thing so
we'll run it through nightbot I'll pull
it actually I can just show you guys
right now
let me show you guys it's actually
pretty uh
it's actually pretty nifty Elwyn is our
top chatter of the night so far so we
just go to like giveaways here
oh my gosh it actually pops up the chat
in real time that's cool so we could
have like a keyword
I don't know how wait how are you guys
how are you guys popping up here I
didn't even give a code word
oh I think it's just any chatter oh
because it's just any active user right
now oh that's cool
so then we will like say a keyword so I
could say like I don't know Hagrid
and then if I if I set that word then
anybody who types that we would roll it
here and then I'm gonna do some so some
of the giveaways are going to be open to
everybody
all you have to do is be a subscriber
which is free be a subscriber but then
we're gonna do some giveaways that are
just for members I gotta reward the
people who've been here supporting so
you see how they have this thing where
you can say like a channel member gets
no extra luck or I could just make it
completely so like if I oh we don't want
hold on I don't want to disable mods
that's not fair
so like if I make it um like I could say
just
channel members so now see it's only
showing me channel members over here or
if I like say just mods
so then Elwyn pops up there
so we're gonna have some that I'll do
I'll do just for uh channel members so
it's pretty it's pretty neat and then
you guys can see right here in real time
that it's totally random everybody type
in hagger now we're not doing it yet
we're not doing it yet don't worry not
yet not yet just going over how things
will work
so yeah dude I'm super pumped
um
everybody's welcome I'm calling it a
Christmas celebration stream that's what
I celebrate whatever you celebrate if
you celebrate Christmas another holiday
around this time it's all good it's all
good Bradley Roberts with the Super Chat
yo Bradley thank you so much Merry
Christmas to you as well my friend Merry
Christmas hope you can make it for the
uh
the Christmas live stream it's gonna be
a good time guys it's gonna be a good
time got a few a few little fun
surprises in store nothing nothing too
crazy but just a different vibe for a
stream We're not gonna be talking
like Hogwarts Legacy you know I'm sure
it'll come up but it's just gonna be
just gonna be a very fun like festive
festive stream been working on the
little scenes we're gonna have some
different scene changes on that one so
I'm I'm pumped for it I'm pumped
all right any any questions about
the uh the Christmas stream
what time is it's gonna be at eight JP 8
P.M Eastern just like the uh just like
our regular streams
Hagrid Legacy
tell you the word defeats the point oh
that'd be hilarious Shadow got it if I
had one that I don't tell anybody oh
that's actually kind of fun
just making a random word and not for at
least one of the giveaways
yeah yeah
that would be funny
Bradley thank you so much for your
support though
just make us guess oh my goodness
legendary gamer Society did I get your
Tweet about the Hogwarts Legacy train
I saw somebody's tweet about um
it was like the the clip of the shot of
hogsmeade right
yeah yeah so we know like the station is
in the game I just don't think we're
gonna be like taking the Hogwarts
Express to school that's my guess
[Music]
be traveling back from Philly yeah it's
all good if you can't make it guys no
worries I will keep the VOD up
um however I mean to to win you have to
be present for the live I wish there
were you know maybe in the future we'll
look at being able to do some other
things
but I just honestly I just want to say
thank you and in a small way to give
back I mean
I don't know about you all but Christmas
for me like growing up over the years as
I really kind of learned like what the
true meaning of it is
it's I mean it all comes back to helping
people you know
helping helping to pick people up so if
if some of you I know some of you had a
hard year I've I've heard from you in
the live streams and in the Discord so
if I hope I hope you guys can get a can
get a small win you know I know it's
right before Christmas so probably
wouldn't help you with any any gifts or
anything but maybe would help you uh get
something nice for yourself
more
but if you can't make it no worries at
all we're I mean I hope I hope it can
become a regular thing I know James has
said his it's like the fourth year he's
been doing his so
the guessing game would be awesome okay
you guys have got me thinking now we're
gonna have to uh
we're gonna have to start thinking about
at least for one of them maybe for one
of the grand prizes for one of the
Hogwarts Legacy copies we'll do
something different
no Wolfie it's on uh this Friday so what
what date is this Friday
the 23rd yeah 23rd this Friday 8 PM
Eastern
8 P.M Eastern this Friday
excited for the winners in advance
Johnny I have a big conspiracy about
robes put my evidence down here we can
go over it
sure sure
get a PS5 Chris nice
eating Ramen for the next few months but
it's worth it
oh you work in healthcare my wife is uh
in healthcare
[Music]
I did Cal yeah
my mentions on Twitter have been getting
have been blowing up about the uh the
Water creature stuff
so yeah I've seen it we're gonna we're
gonna go through the full gameplay
showcase here in a bit
[Music]
secret word number one Merlin right
right
a sounds good Jenny have a good dinner
hey I appreciate that dark lord
appreciate that that I mean that's
that's the goal honestly that's the goal
like that when I first started
every job I've ever had career-wise
I always knew I would need something
where I could be helping people in in
some way so I've worked in education
I've worked in like
for public libraries that's where I work
now is for Public Library
and like I still enjoy doing that stuff
and like I I help a lot of people that
way but when I saw the power of YouTube
and like how many people you can reach
it's insane like when I look at just
like when I look at the YouTube sends
you a little thing at the end of the
year that's like your channel recap for
the year
you can see like how many comments you
got how many views you got how many
likes you got
and dude I'm still like I still remember
when when a video hit a hundred views
how excited I would get and now seeing
how many likes I'm getting on videos
it's like it's just so even if even if
you're just like making a tiny small
positive impact just that anybody looks
forward in my videos dude it it makes me
excited warms my heart David not sure I
could stay up we'll go to bed and catch
up in the morning hey all good David I
hope that we'll be able to fix that one
day you know
maybe one day maybe one day if we ever
do this this streaming thing full time
then we will uh we'll move up that time
but see then there's like then I'm like
do I leave some of the audience behind
you know because so many of you guys are
used to this APM time slot
laughs
Amore poet I saw your comment earlier
about the uh
the slow mode
yeah it got it started getting really
crazy on the gameplay showcase so
I have kept it on
all right guys let's hop into so if if
you're wondering what's been playing
if you uh don't follow every single
Hogwarts Legacy news item they just
shared these four videos just in time
for the holidays yo how about that
Chandler how about that my friend
Chandler
[Music]
check out who's got the most views guys
check out who's got the most fuse
oh dude I was giving Chandler hard time
on Twitter because when
so it's hilarious we were a couple of us
were hanging out Nick specto goes twitch
stream I think you were there Jenny and
somebody posted like Hogwarts Legacy new
video and
he and I were looking on Twitter I was
like Chad is trolling James there's
nothing here
then they said YouTube so we went to
YouTube and found these four videos
and so I think I I actually tweeted it
out before Chandler even posted it
officially and so when I posted mine I
of course linked the Gryffindor
I link the Gryffindor video and then
Chandler shared it on the Hogwarts I
assume it's Chandler anyway shared it on
the Hogwarts Legacy account of course he
links the Slytherin video first so I had
to give him a hard time for that but now
I think I think it's funny to see the
breakdown now looks like uh the
Gryffindor went just edging out
Slytherin so gryffindor's got 100K view
Slytherin at 91 then you got Ravenclaw
65 Hufflepuff at 55. oh sorry
hufflepuffs
sorry hufflepuffs
so yeah I had to give Chandler a hard
time but if you're wondering what those
are
um it's these four new videos they
shared this week of each common room
fireplace and also some just like
festive festive holiday music 4K videos
they're so good they're so good Karthik
love your videos retro really missed the
old intro just a dad who loves games
with the stories they tell
oh goodness excuse me
um I haven't even started my drink yet
but it is I do need to hydrate
Noob would be proud
and we also had a who he does it
renewing their tier one membership Hui
thank you so much for being a channel
member here member of House rack and
tour
I meant I I meant to start saying that
at the beginning of every live stream
Karthik because I agree with you I love
the intro
I don't know if you've heard my whole
spiel about why I don't do it in videos
anymore but I do try and do it in live
streams totally forgot tonight so
if you guys are new here people of the
internet I'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell
but yeah the reason I don't do it on uh
all my videos anymore is because people
have very very short attention spans
you wouldn't think that it would matter
for like
tiny intros but dude I'll tell you when
I started changing it is I had a video
this was a while ago
but I had a video where like one of the
first comments was video starts at
and you know how people can put the
little time stamp and it was like 30
something seconds into the video and I
was just like
dude it's it's true it's true like I
have people have the internet retro
wrecking tour here just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell so
here's what's been going on in the
Hogwarts Legacy news we're going to be
covering this this and this today now
let's get into it and let's get into it
is why people click the video so but I
do agree with you it's a good intro I
need to just remember to do it on the
live streams Noob with another Super
Chat Noob I'm so proud of you retro good
job on hydrating buddy everyone else
remember to stay hydrated I don't think
you guys would be able to guess mine
tonight
I don't think I've ever had this
I've never had this exact beverage on a
live stream
never had this exact beverage see if
anybody can get it I'm not even I'm not
going to hold it close to the camera but
I'm not gonna try and hide it either
see if anybody can get it there
somebody uh Professor Baxter I've never
seen these reveals in trailer until
retro covers them oh my professor Baxter
you saw the you saw the new uh showcase
though right
you saw that right and you'll see a wide
so that's what we're going to be going
over mostly tonight guys
the fireplace is super relaxing you'll
be seeing more of those in our video on
uh
in our not our video in our live stream
on Friday
uh yeah good night Jenny good night
okay somebody says uh
Cherry Coke see Cherry Coke is my well
Cherry Coke Zero is my usual go-to ether
says Vanilla Coke good guess
Moon Lily Coca-Cola Gigi's a lobster egg
oh lots of eggnog guesses cream soda
a Mori poet I think I'm gonna ask us up
for your channel for Christmas any
advice for a guy who hasn't seen
anything since late October
are you kidding me oh my buck buckle up
Amore poet buckle up
because you're about this this video
we're about to watch here
oh my oh my Waterloo Black Tracy now
that'd be too obvious Logan
the Coca-Cola is the closest so far
Timothy got it nice Timothy
yeah so normally I drink Cherry Coke
Zero tonight just a regular Coke Zero
because they were out
of the Cherry Coke Zeros
excuse me
it's giving me the hiccups now
Jenny hydrating with a glass of wine at
the moment oh yeah a couple of other
people then said Coke Zero nice nice
Mountain Dew Code Red peach tea for Neil
Harrison fizzy water
no how could you rap true
oh dude butterbeer would be great
Johnny the hustle puff wrestle 46 305
410 49 of the Gameplay trailer these
show our companions with color stripe oh
yeah yeah I do remember you saying that
all right here's what I want to know
Johnny since you've been analyzing all
the robes
what do you think about the robes at the
end of the gameplay showcase
all right I know we're going out of
order but this is the scene that's got
everybody talking
this is the scene that's got everybody
talking right here
here let's back up a little bit I'm
going to turn this up super loud too
because somebody just pointed out
there's a little voice that you can hear
in the background I don't know if it's
like our character or if it's the book
talking I think it's the book talking
I'm just gonna rewind it for a little
bit all right so volume all the way up
here
here too
foreign
and then notice the robe here totally
different from the robe that we see
Sebastian in is it quidditch robes is it
just I mean they've already showed us so
many different types of styles right
maybe it's just a different style of
rope
all right let's go back I'm gonna let
you guys hear it one more time
listen for like this this weird kind of
whispering
I know right I did I didn't pick up it
on on it either the first time
I saw uh somebody tweeted a bunch of us
about it that's where I saw it all right
so yeah I I don't know why the robes are
old there
and I don't know what the whispering if
it's if it's the book I mean everybody's
thinking horcrux here's the thing that I
want to say about the horror Crux
if you remember
Tom Riddle's Diary
let's talk about that for a bit so yes
it was a horcrux
however the way that I always understood
that diary
is I understood it as a
because think about the other horcruxes
most of them were just standard objects
that he had chosen right hufflepuff's
cup
so
um they were the the locket I mean they
were they were just physical objects
they didn't really do anything however
the diary I almost get the sense that
the diary is was like its own separate
magical item
and then it was also a horcrux
if that makes sense right so even if
this is exactly like Riddle's Diary I
don't think that that automatically
means it's a horcrux EFA Spartan with a
super chat James and Ben's Theory sent
me to conclude that the four founder I
think you mean four Founders right the
four vaults might be a part of it since
it first has a broken wand and book in
it dude Spartan thank you for the Super
Chat I I haven't watched Ben and uh
James's entire stream I I was there for
a majority of it
um and heard part of the theory so let
me read this again James and Ben's
Theory sent me to conclude that the four
vaults might be a part of it since the
first has a broken wand
and book in it
I'm not sure what you mean by four
vaults
I'm not sure what you mean by more
vaults
all the founders items hufflepuff's cup
slytherins locket and ravenclaws died
and had magical powers of their own
before they became horcrux as the books
don't spelled out oh interesting
is that like in a is that like a
Pottermore thing or something a Mori
poet
does the book act like newt's briefcase
man I think the uh that little Satchel
we see our carrier our character
carrying is more the briefcase
all right so we'll get to that at the
end I was looking to see if Johnny had a
thought
I'm a Believer our players from the
future what oh my goodness okay before I
jump back to the beginning I was I was
messaging James about this because I was
curious to see
what he was thinking I think he's
probably already figured it out with his
theory
um I mean it's for so one thing we know
for sure guys it is the the book that
you see is the book from the collector's
edition that much is is pretty much
certain
um it is also
should I say highly likely I think it's
pretty likely that it's that it's
Merlin's book but what I was asking
James is I was like dude what if this
like we see this character wearing a
different style robe what if this was
actually Merlin and we're seeing like a
shot in the past but then we got we
started looking closer at the other
items in the like so this looks a lot
like Phineas Phineas black so we're
thinking that it's probably current you
know
present day Hogwarts Legacy era
but um yeah I don't know and then who is
this like is this just a player
character or is it someone else
or is it someone else
but clearly some people were saying Port
key so if you remember Port keys I'm
pretty sure travel with the person
that's definitely how it's depicted in
the movies and I'm pretty sure you guys
correct me if I'm wrong I'm pretty sure
that's how it works in the books as well
Amore poet said it's mentioned in the
books the old fat lady who had a crush
on Tom Riddle talked about the cup and
lock it all having sorts of power she
hadn't discovered them all okay gotcha
but see then like the diary is like
almost like its own thing
that he somehow
Enchanted to do that
I guess what I'm getting at is I don't
think it's because of the horror because
it's not because it's a horcrux right
what if the book acts like a pensive
instead of taking memories out and
putting them in you're writing memories
down and can revisit them in the same
way
it's like so why wouldn't they
we know there's pensives in the game
but why wouldn't they why would this I
guess what would be the significance of
having it through a book instead
so what would be the significance of
that
I think it has to be horcrux um in Harry
Potter Tom Riddle's book was it was like
the black smoke when he was inside
that's right JP yeah you have to hold on
to the uh
exactly you have to hold on to it
oh my gosh shadow guy oh
Mutiny become the replacement are you uh
are you trying to play some Skyrim here
College of Winterhold
all right let's jump back to the
beginning because there's there's so
much to talk about
I'm gonna put the volume which I love
that we can you can walk out of the
castle after walking actually you know
what let's put the volume
room out into the open world and Alex
kind of low here particularly so they
started off they showed us three
different sections and guys I have uh I
have not put out a deep dive video yet
mainly because I haven't had time to do
a full Deep dive so we're going to kind
of do it here together a little bit so
they showed off three things the open
world and then they showed off Advanced
combat and then the room of requirement
you can walk out of the castle and first
of all I mean I think the game is just
looking it's looking really nice really
nice now there are still some technical
issues throughout I know I've seen some
people talking about pop in and some
texture things but just like from a pure
artistic View
that looks incredible
that looks incredible I can't wait to
just and the fact that I mean Alan talks
here in a little bit about how you can
just like
if you just want to fly back over to the
castle and you're just you're just right
back in assumingly with no loading times
they haven't outright said that take off
on your broom out into the open world
and Alan I know that's something that
you particularly Alan loves talking
about the brew images I'm a big fan of
just being able to I mean so all this
like this is our best shot yet and
remember how they talked last time like
anywhere you see you can go there about
Hogwarts Legacy yeah I'm uh I'm a big
fan of just being able to hop on the
broom and go anywhere there's something
about kind of like the the sensation of
of everything yeah it'd be just it'd be
disappointing Antoine if there are load
times for sure close to the ground and
and I I kind of wanted to talk about it
just because I feel like
um you know the brooms are fun for me
not just because of all those feelings
of exhilaration but
4K version room and it's done uh I
actually kind of like some of the
mechanics in it so you can now here's
here's where we can really start
breaking stuff down right right the mini
map
so as our character starts to take off
many of you have probably already
figured out what a lot of these are
so there are some obvious ones right so
you've got like your your direction so
you got East South West North here so it
looks like it rotates depending on where
where you're facing and then you've got
the green ones which are pretty
obviously the flu Flames we see a flu
flame right back
oh wait we actually may not see it in
this shot let's see
and we're starting right where we left
off now no they're not so I bet
I bet our character just like used the
flu flame to travel last gameplay
showcase just outside Hogwarts which
kind of pan around right there you can
walk out of the castle after I did play
ajd I heard the same thing let me turn
it up
walking through everything and then just
come out here and take off on your broom
out into the open world and Alan I know
that's something that you so then we
gotta we've got the flu icon here this
yellow one I'm I'm thinking that might
just be our like your next Quest
destination or maybe a marker that
you've put on the map particularly like
about Hogwarts Legacy too yeah and then
very faintly you can see like the little
paths
I'm uh I'm a big fan of just being able
to hop on the broom and go anywhere
there's something about kind of Casey
the sensation of of everything being
open to you and just I love the
proximity that I can get to things I
love flying close to the ground and all
right and then right away we get another
one we get this little question mark
right here
and we see a couple of NPCs over here
and then this left one here I think this
is going to be like um
oh what's the word like a little area
that you have to clear
foreign
I can't think of the word right now like
almost like a little dungeon area or
something
Noisy Boy yo thank you for the Super
Chat Noisy Boy do you think there will
be more books at the end of the Showcase
to find to learn this more secrets of
ancient Magic
oh I never thought about it like that
that is something they did like that
mechanic they kind of used that in the
old games if you guys played the old
games they would have like spell books
at the end of the area so you would just
be uh
that's how you would learn new spells
you would get to the end and there's
like a little spell book hey good to see
you Nathan Merry Christmas to you as
well
I wonder if they will release a demo
prior to release so we can get a feel
for the game be excited for a demo I
don't know that's a good question
I wonder if that depends on like
pre-order data or something when how how
companies decide whether they want to do
a demo or not like my my gut is no just
because I feel like this is uh
enough marketing behind it which
Speaking of marketing I wonder where
we're going to start to see commercials
and stuff all right here's another
flu flame which okay that one's not
green
that one is not green so does that mean
it hasn't been discovered but then why
would it pop up on the map
and discovered it why would it show up
at all
and then right here I wonder if this is
uh I'm thinking these are Quest givers
like the little uh speech bubble
said previously you can turn the map HUD
off I hope for more granule absolutely
yes for sure I I hope that we'll have
options to turn certain things off
yeah I'm guessing that these okay so now
we see another very similar one so we
got this yellow here
and I'm guessing that is one that we
ourselves have marked or maybe that's
like your primary Quest and then this
similar symbol right here is a secondary
Quest like a side quest or something
I know Professor Baxter I saw some
people saying it looks like there's not
much to do in the world I was like are
you looking at the same video I am
because there are icons everywhere
which to the point about being having a
granular nature being able to turn
certain things off yeah I agree if you
want to be able to go for that full
immersion I feel like you will be
the channel
all right so I want to make sure we
didn't miss anything right there uh I
actually kind of like some of them so we
got the speech bubble mechanics in it so
you and then you've got these treasure
chests I'm assuming that's just flute
that we can find little secrets and
right here I do remember seeing this one
you have like this purple flame
which that might just be with that
little shopkeeper right there
but you know what's interesting is the
shot actually kind of like something
that happens so you can you see in the
lower right there's the shopkeeper
doesn't have an icon
that's interesting
tons and tons of missions little quests
to do around the world yeah I feel like
that too
I feel like that too
oh amore poet yeah character creation uh
was on uh James our buddy expect to go
got to go and attend one of these
he was the first guest I didn't realize
you hadn't seen that either Maury poet
oh my goodness
yeah so check that out that they showed
the full character creator in that yeah
there's a meter there and and
occasionally as oh yeah so Alan's
talking about the meter now right here
so this is a big difference from when
you're riding on Broom versus when
you're riding on a creature
so with a broom you have two meters down
here you've got the green which is your
health and then you've got yellow which
is basically like a speed boost to this
broom I'll just I'll let him do the
talking here
Andrew's kind of flying up or flying
down you might notice it in draining or
not and and this isn't the present day
where all the broom technology is well
known and advanced and and all right I
love that I love that that they
it's like okay they they obviously know
they gotta have broom flight in the game
people are going to want broom flight in
some form but it can't be like the Harry
Potter Nimbus 2000 Nimbus 2001 the fire
bolts it's got to be a little more
primitive there's got to be a something
that you know it doesn't work quite as
well the technology hasn't Advanced
enough just yet
so I love that they Incorporated it into
the story a little bit there and so it
looks like we've got another question
mark icon coming up and everything that
we know and love this is an earlier time
where there's still ooh and it we see it
briefly pop up well known and advanced
and and watch right in here there's a
little white and everything that we know
and love this isn't right there
go back frame by frame it takes a little
longer to load when you're watching it
in 4k
uh
oh that I I know you're joking Jace but
I don't think you can cast spells there
it is that little icon right there
I don't know if that's just something in
yeah that does not look I don't think
that's the question mark spot because
that looks like it is more that way
so this might just be another
interactable item
but to your point to your point there
Jace we were talking about that on the
live stream with uh
on Friday all the Hogwarts creators we
were talking about
um I don't think you can cast spells on
broom or when you're riding an animal
because though those icons the spell
icons go away
they go away whenever you uh
hop onto the broom and yes so many
people asking can you leap off the broom
like when you're flying high above in
the earlier timer they're still trying
to figure out
we're at the 11.
so they're like the version 11 of our
Nimbus hey Christy welcome Christy so
happy to have found this community is so
grateful to be able to contribute y'all
are amazing Christy thank you so much
for being a member here
Christy also a moderator here on the
channel
um Christy's been in the process of
moving which is never an easy thing to
do never an easy thing to do
Nimbus 11 I know right I don't think
no we're not listening and and
everything that we know and love this is
an earlier time where they're still
trying to figure out you know we're not
at the 3000 yet we're like we're at the
11. so I just I'm just so and then you
have this icon over here looks like
another sort of uh like dungeon
Cavern area to explore so the little
leaf icons those are Merlin puzzles
I don't know if you should say Merlin
puzzles for sure they're definitely uh
puzzles but I I'm pretty sure they're
the Merlin puzzles because right now
because this is just so beautiful
now with this thing they speed by this
this little like
I don't think it's a sign
at first it looks like a giant just a
giant head
almost like some sort of weird scarecrow
but I don't think it's that I think it
more might it might be like a lighting
thing or like a globe of some sort
why would it be Nimbus 11 is my math
broken I I think he was just joking
Rodrigo he was just showing that it's
nowhere near as advanced as what they uh
what they have in Harry Potter's day
weird rock formation I don't think it's
part of the rock formation I think it's
like some sort of like
I don't know like a statue or a planter
of some kind
foreign
puzzles yeah ancient magic puzzles that
might be a better way of saying it but
they so in the first trailer they talked
about the things being left behind by
Merlin himself I'm guessing all of them
are Merlin but maybe not so here we get
an we get a little view oh yeah and
there's another one of those things
right there and right there and right
there three more
would be more of those little circular
things
huh
uh that's that's what we're all trying
to figure out a bory poet we're all
we're breaking it all down here on our
deep Dives so yeah there's the one with
that little like leaf pattern for a
Merlin puzzle and then you see our first
look at what enemies look like or in
this case
uh hostile creatures so we see these
creatures over here on the right and
then you also see them which it looks
like there's three to me one two three
but then I only see two arrows so there
might be some overlapping there
the broom is like the only one oh wait
there's a close-up
there's this little statue by the way
the The Brood is that like there
oh it's got like little holes in it on
the side oh I bet it's like something
for owls or something for Birds might be
a little too small for owls
to like kind of go in and out like a
little birdhouse I could see them being
like perched on the side here
hopefully the puzzles aren't as
confusing as POA if you guys saw my uh
let's plays of prisoner of azkman you
already know
you already know I struggle with way too
many of those
well they do have gifting on mobile you
just it's a setting you have to turn off
but they don't have this oh they don't
have the setting on mobile so I guess
once you change the setting then maybe
you could uh
happy Christmas Sharon thank you for
being here one or can you like operate
the room
so
not everyone shows up on the menu so you
saw there was an NPC walking there yeah
so we have uh been been asking a good
question about upgrading you know how
does it do you get new brooms
and then they're going to explain stop
and Hog's meat actually a broom shop and
so that sells a variety of different
brooms and it was important to us that
the player could customize themselves
based on their own Aesthetics so they're
purely cosmetic but uh if you talk to
the shopkeep and help them out they'll
actually sell upgrades
yeah and those
and then you also see a lot of these
popping up
you see a lot of these popping up
these little challenges
dueling Feats complete the battle in
time and you only get 10 seconds so you
got to be quick whatever
their own aesthetic so they're purely
cosmetic but uh if you man I wish we
could see what creature there's another
red indicator right here so there's a
creature here so why does this flu based
on their own aesthetic so they're purely
cosmetic but I guess it's going to show
up as you get close to it even if you
haven't discovered it yet that's sort of
strange
and then it then it just turns green
when you when you activate if you talk
to the shopkeep and help him out he'll
actually sell upgrades
and those those upgrades will make it so
that where normally the broom you can
only all right another uh
puzzle coming up ancient magic puzzle
why
um you can only go at Max Speed it's
kind of like a turbo meter down there
you can only go at Max Speed without the
meter going down kind of closer to the
ground so did you hear that from Alan
this is this is a big uh
a big thing about how the broom is
different from the creatures that we can
mount and fly so as you raise into the
air oh wait hold on let's back up the
broom you can only fly
um you can only go at Max Speed it's
kind of like a turbo meter down there
you can only go at Max Speed without the
meter going down kind of closer to the
ground and as you raise into they're
going to go up you notice the meter drop
and so they'll watch that people allow
you to increase that distance from the
ground and there the the broom owner at
at the sporting goods store in in
hogsmead is trying to perfect the broom
and get better at it and and know it
better and you can participate that and
get better and better brooms through
this I see so it sounds like you're
going to be able to you can fly higher
but you're just going to be really slow
until you get more of those upgrades and
then um is it McKenzie I think is her
name Mackenzie toner
I believe hold on I don't I don't want
to get her name wrong here dark arts
battle arena
even see
just outside Hogwarts which I I love
that we can you can walk out
I'm honored to introduce you to our this
happened too hello everybody capturing
gameplay for us oh we went too far yeah
Mackenzie toner dark lord Aeron with
another Super Chat
uh also Jessica and Jared subscribe to
the channel thank you so much so if we
manifested the jump post previously
tonight dude dark lord Aeron we tried we
tried last
we tried on
the day before when did we try guys
when did we try we tried
maybe we need to try it again I think it
was before this showcase we tried
I thought they were about to show it
dude I really did because they got close
to the water as we'll see here in a
second
as we see here in a second
hey Osiris welcome doing well my friend
doing well
all right so yeah McKenzie uh told told
Ben here when he asked the question
about the brooms that
uh you can basically change the
cosmetics
which is is good I know a lot of ground
to me it feels like it's got this kind
of Surfing let's back up a little bit
more to explore on the ground and so
kind of keeping
here you notice the meter drops
we're only three months that sells a
variety
yeah so we have uh stop in Hog's meat
actually a broom shop and so that sells
a variety of different brooms and it was
important to us that the player could
customize themselves based on their own
aesthetic so they're purely cosmetic so
remember that purely cosmetic that seems
to be a thing that they are focusing on
they want the up they want you to have
ways to upgrade your gear but they want
you to be able to look how you want to
look
that is going to apply to gear as well
as the broom here so we learned here
early that it applies to the broom
but it's also going to apply to gear
here in a bit too
legit had a dream of another new
showcase and they made the character
dive
even while asleep I'm trying to Manifest
this and make it happen
Osiris I know quidditch isn't playable
do you think the Quidditch State stadium
is explorable
just want to fly around on it oh
I feel like they I don't think
I don't think quidditch is gonna be just
not and mentioned in the game at all I
just don't think we'll be able to play
Quidditch so I don't see why you
wouldn't be able to fly around the
stadium that'd be kind of weird if you
fly to it and then it just like blocks
you out
maybe I mean maybe it does like if
there's people playing practicing or
something
I mean I could even see a quidditch
appearing in a story Mission at some
point like we're having to do something
during a story Mission and like a
quidditch match is going on yeah I think
so another Super Chat coming in from
Wolfie there can we manifest Patronus
they have not confirmed Patronus they
have not confirmed I think a Patronus
will be in the game just uh if you talk
to the shopkeeper I mean they're showing
off all these dark art spells are you
kidding me like you're gonna give us all
the unforgivables you gotta have expecto
patronum come on Gotta Have expecto
patronum Dustin with another Super Chat
Dustin thank you for your support I'm
willing to bet there is swimming and
deep diving I want to say that mermaid
city under the Black Lake will be
explorable to a point that's some of the
rest of the iceberg that's underwater
yeah Chandler gave a whether intended or
not he has given the fandom another
little tease when he said near the end
of this showcase he talks about
everything we we've seen being the tip
of the iceberg
so it's so funny what people like fixate
on and uh
and want to talk about you know
like the like the my video about jumping
oh man just when I feel like I I am
starting to understand YouTube I was
like okay this is not really a huge
story but I'll make a video on it that
jump video is going crazy
going absolutely crazy
oh yeah Mori poet you you got a lot of
catching up to do
are you do you like travel or something
Maury poet do you do like um just like
no internet at all for a while
I know some people who like to do uh oh
what do you call it not like sabbatical
but like a uh
where you just turn off all social media
for a while
I know right I'm like wait what yeah all
unforgivables check out just just go go
to my channel go to the videos look look
at the recent and you you'll get caught
up pretty quick
you'll get caught up
Ben and James all at one with the
excitement right right
internet cleanse yeah yeah
love Lynette's jump short yes Alicia I
saw that too but yeah like that video
has just blown up all about people
actually and so the the swimming is
another thing that I'm surprised so many
people are interested in so yeah we
could totally just see I could see
Chandler doing a tweet one day upgrades
trying out another one word like those
upgrades will make it so that where
normally the broom you can only fly
um you can only go at Max Speed it's
kind of like a turbo meter down there
you can only go at Max Speed without so
you got some little signs there kind of
showing off some other areas into the
air you'll notice the meter dropped and
so those upgrades will allow you to
increase that distance from the ground
and there the the broom owner yeah there
you go at the sporting goods store in in
hogsmead is trying to perfect the broom
and give them around a bit better and
you can participate that and get better
and better brooms through this I've cut
back and I love that mechanic I don't do
things to actually explore the world and
kind of stay close to the ground it's
not just to travel like YouTube I don't
even really like some I guess YouTube is
I mean it is social media in a way but I
can I can never give up YouTube
I could definitely totally give up
Facebook probably even Twitter at some
point I don't really I'm on Instagram
but I know it might be you're not just
flying high over everything although it
is beautiful something I really love
okay here's here's another uh two more
little challenges over here on the right
use a mandrake against an enemy and keep
an enemy Airborne for 10 seconds so like
I wonder what is prompting these to pop
up oh here's a new Icon by the way
actually explore the world and kind of
stay close to the ground it see if we
can catch just what's over here point A
to point B
right there when they make that turn oh
there it is there it is is that a
graveyard
oh interesting
and dude wait what is
oh man it's I think it's just blue smoke
but for a second I was like wait is that
a Patronus Fork
I'm trying to make it happen is that a
Patronus there
what is that
what is going on over there
oh amorepo said life has just gotten
really busy haven't seen anything it's
laid out sober oh my goodness had to
step up at my church in a big way gosh
okay I was like how did you just like
are you have you been traveling or
something I see I see I know five
there's a Patronus I see it but yeah
like I wonder if this graveyard is that
what this icon over here is
but then it is a graveyard right chat it
just looks it looks like a small
graveyard so we got like these three
headstones here
I mean this looks like this looks like a
shot right out of Eldon ring right here
it's flying and then they just go buy it
everything although okay yeah so it is
like a little a little Cemetery here so
that is definitely what this icon here
is
it is beautiful something I really love
doing but as well there's lots too and
then we lost here hold on over
everything I'm gonna be quiet and listen
this time as we go past this graveyard
explore the world now to stay close to
the ground it's not just a travel
mechanic point A to point B you're not
just flying high over everything
although it is beautiful something I
really love doing but as well what the
heck is it sounds like a creature well
there's lots too oh and there is there's
a red
you can barely see the red there's like
watch watch right here there's like a
red indicator that's going to appear
underneath the uh the grave High over
everything although it is beautiful
something I really love doing but as
well there's lots to lots to explore on
the ground and so kind of keeping you
down at the ground to me it feels like
it's got this kind of Surfing Vibe over
there growling
okay then you get more another chest
another question mark match the
controller from Andrew right now because
I want to go to the Mountaintop I'm
going to the forest enter the Hamlet or
a little uh I don't know that's how it's
cold no it's awesome
oh man I loved watching Ben on this Ben
been talking about he's getting a little
ahead of himself he's like is that what
it's called
and then Alan's like actually that is
what we've been referring to the men's
we're gonna we're actually gonna land
here and I I feel like okay so there's
people call it a hamlet is is white it's
just perfect just because that's what we
refer to that and so uh we all know for
more that hogsmeade is the only all
Wizarding village within Britain but we
wanted other opportunities to kind of
meet other characters out here and to
kind of populate the landscape so it's
not just kind of you know Barren as you
leave out this direction dude look I
wonder if these kids are playing like
gobstones or something over here
and so we just imagine these different
dwellings these different smaller
locations that that Wizards might live
in out in the Scottish Highlands and so
it's those uh and so for 10 galleons
are we are we a rich wizard here
Jay quit the Super Chat Jake what is up
my friend at the end of the Showcase
when the character got sucked into the
book do you think we're going into
someone's memories possible substations
like Harry did also do you college
football oh I love football Jake I did
see your question earlier sorry I forgot
to answer that one yeah yeah big
football fan
um so yeah I think I think we're
definitely going into memories of some
sort for sure at that end scene I think
the big question is why is it like
through a book
I don't think it's a horcrux but I do I
I do feel that's a legitimate question
to be asking and then is it Merlin is it
Merlin or morgana's book yeah
Dustin with another Super Chat as well
Jake and Dustin thank you guys for the
love and support Dustin says that white
flu flame is unlocked in a second but
doesn't show the location name at least
I think that's the one he walks by okay
so like stuff like that I I wonder if
it's like a story mode thing too like
the harder difficulty you set like if
certain icons like I don't know I just
don't feel like the flu Flame
how those different locations have kind
of like learned to live what their
relationships are with characters that
Hogs me from Hogwarts oh we can see
there's another so we got another leaf
and then some icon underneath there I
can't tell what it is right now oh I
think that I think that might have been
and so they're both Quest opportunities
out here and a chance to kind of get to
know more of the area even Beyond
Hogwarts and hogsmead that we've already
experienced and you also noticed on the
new map like lots of little icons and
each one of those represents gameplay in
in the hamlets that you can participate
in you know whether it's a vendor or
different puzzles and challenges or
different secrets that exist
um each one of those icons are different
opportunities for gameplay and you'll
hold on I was trying to catch up
uh somebody's asking about the IGM
footage love to hear my take on the
audio yes so if you guys didn't know
there is um
IGN uploaded it's the same footage that
we saw but it's no commentary
so you can crank the audio up and
several of us in the Discord have been
able to discover more spells
that I I didn't catch in just viewing
this we'll see here when we get to the
combat scene but that that is a good
idea that is a good idea I don't know if
we'll have time to do it on this stream
but
because yeah just in watching it for
like I've only watched the combat scene
so far without audio and just watching
that one though you pick up you pick up
several things
you can see on the building that the
Hamlet's name is Cambridge nice fueled
by the fire thank you
yeah yeah Tom yeah there is a
notice that same thing as we venture out
into the I don't know maybe if anyone
else uploaded it or if like I don't know
how they got it I assume WB or Avalanche
provided them with that like unedited
just raw footage of that
but yeah it's it's really it gives you a
feel for the sound effects in the game
like The crucial oh my gosh you guys
sound effects on crucio all right so we
got three question marks here and yet
again confirmation that the vendors
do not show up on the map so when you go
out into the open world and you see see
those icons whether they're on the mini
map or on your map or off in the
distance those things are opportunities
to say like I want to increase my
inventory capacity their puzzles left
behind by old Wizards you know that you
can solve how he says old Wizards
just just hurting our boy James a little
bit
yeah if you guys uh Nico's letting you
know some of the spells that you can
hear
or actually I don't know I don't
remember
yeah they're talking about somebody
something else but they're talking about
spells I don't think those are any that
I heard in this uh
in this showcase yeah
I think I'll probably play on normal
first as well
that actually Grant you those if you see
ruins off in the off in the distance
and as you and as you kind of counter
tonight enemies dotted on the landscape
sometimes those characters what do you
guys think
sitting confirmed yes or no
I'm gonna get I'm gonna give you some
evidence in favor and I'm gonna give you
some evidence against right here in this
very scene
well obviously it's not confirmed either
way so what do you get do you guys feel
like sitting is going to be in or not
yes or no
Christy says yes Logan says of course
yes yes Jenny the first hard to say Spud
says no
Professor Baxter says poll
it's literally highlighted okay
that's where I was going ether that's
where I was going the chair is
highlighted but to you and as you kind
of encountered this thing started on the
landscape sometimes those characters
right up to the stool
no no sitting prompt appears no button
prompt okay I would say
let's let's take away the captions for a
second
are we closer to the cup or are we
closer to the chair because we're
getting a prompt on the cup
but we're not getting a prompt on the
chair
so the chair is clearly highlighted
though
I think it's highlighted for
for
um
a pug no
because remember how we can like enter
take objects and interact with them and
like cast a pug no and sling it at
enemies like you see it with all those
barrels
this is another one of those things that
I'm so like fascinated by that people
are so curious in this people are so
curious that you see Spud that's what
I'm thinking like it's it's a spell
people so want to know if you can sit or
not
okay I am going to do a poll I do want
to do a poll and I'm going to change it
though I want to know I want to know how
many of you care
do you care about being able to sit in
Hogwarts Legacy these are the polls that
really matter these are the polls that
really matter because personally like
I could not care less
I could not care less
to those of you who care about it that's
great it's awesome I hope I hope it's in
there for you do you care about being
able to sit in Hogwarts like it's a yes
or no okay I'm asking the community
dreaming plays games with the Super Chat
hey dreaming thank you so much found
your Channel about a month ago
subscribed after like four videos best
channel for Hogwarts Legacy news I say a
dream and thank you for the support I'm
glad you enjoyed the videos I'm glad you
found the channel and I I thank you for
the Super Chat as well yeah it's it's
been a blast covering this game for sure
for sure
Wolfie says is the question that we can
sit in the chair just in general
that's a good question
I mean in this case in this scenario I'm
wondering what you guys think about
right here what you think about right
here
because I feel like if you could like
why would you not sit at the bar and
take the drink
instead
then the Highlight jumps to over there I
don't think the Highlight is for sitting
I do not think it is now I'm maybe you
could still sit but I don't think that
highlight is for sitting I think it's
for a spell magical resources that are
valuable to you and then you see it pop
the little the little white Arrow pops
up
or the little white diamond popped up
over here
so dark Wizards might be hoarding
different uh magical resources that are
available to you as you're playing the
game so each one has oh I don't think
you can guys I don't think you can you
get another Square over the mug over
there but never anything over the chair
like a way to connect to our gameplay
loops and provide different
opportunities that just kind of I hope
I'm not ruining somebody's dreams right
now
I'll be running a fly like oh and that's
me like I can't think of any game ever
I'm trying to think of anything where
I've ever cared about being able to sit
in a game I'm trying to think about it I
mean I guess like Destiny there's
there's little emotes where you can sit
uh same thing for like the souls games
but it's more just like a
I don't use those things for fun it's
just like for comedic effect or
something Antoine I agree City's not a
concern for me at all oh my gosh 53
right now 53 say they care about being
able to sit we've got 153 votes right
now if you haven't voted in the poll
guys do you care about being able to sit
in Hogwarts Legacy
54 right now saying yes 46 say no
this is another one of those things it
just it cracks me up so many people want
to know this
kind of want to sit in a place in the
countryside and chill out
I mean but like for a game you would get
the same thing by just standing there
right Jenny right
now for your from your character's
perspective like if you want to be fully
immersed
you're not if you're standing if you're
if you're like I just want to relax out
in this field and you choose hopefully
there are some places where you where
you can like I just don't feel like
I don't feel like that highlight is for
sitting
fueled by the fire okay Theory here
Theory the stool is not highlighted
hope it did the thing where it jumps
around
oh I totally lost you're a wizard Harry
most MMO RPGs do it's not an MMO though
remember it's not an MMO
just an open world action RPG which did
like did The Witcher let you sit does
Elders does Skyrim let you sit
see I I've played all both those games
extensively can't even tell you if you
can sit or not because I probably never
used it if you could
some people say we 100 can this is not
combat when you throw something The
Prompt is R1 yeah that's true Eskimo R1
for combat R1 does usually appear
but we do have our spells right over
here maybe we just don't know a pugno
yet
like what is the point of the Highlight
though right
did we just not get close enough to the
chair and why did the Highlight appear
let's let's watch oh no I messed up what
did I do
what did I do and you'll see a wide
variety of enemies we're gonna jump to
that point
we want to go back to the uh I was just
gonna let that play again so learn those
wizard stories
sometimes those characters
you guys watch it again and then
opportunities to actually catch them and
learn about your ancient magic and oh
now that's a good point Neil
that's a good point if we can place
Furniture in the room of requirement it
would be a waste not to be able to use
any of it I think that's the biggest
evidence I've seen yet
that you'll be able to sit at least in
some areas like for sure there
you could put all those chairs surely
you'll be able to sit sit in them but
maybe it's like if you make the really
tiny ones like who's that is that for
the house elves or if you can make a
really big one do you have like
half giant friends that come over or
something
oh man imagine they announced a first
person mode oh that'd be interesting
that would be interesting the glitch
witch nice touch not a deal breaker
don't care honestly stool is not
highlighted oh here's the post I was
trying to find the stool is not
highlighted because too many
interactables will will result in a bad
experience you don't want to interact
with the wrong items so they spread it
out
yeah yeah
that's a good point Hannah like those
cozy all the couch areas in the common
rooms
I'll be fine if we can't but I
appreciate anything immersive we can do
oh and like think about the Great Hall
we haven't even seen the Great Hall yet
I mean we've seen it in the
we've seen it in the trailer like as a
cut scene but like actually being able
to walk around in there
so you'll definitely be sitting in there
like at meal times right
hope we'll be able to lay in our bed at
Hogwarts in the dorm rooms
Amore poet I can't imagine being like
not seeing as much as you've been out of
the loop on and then coming back to this
I mean yeah this was our biggest look
yet at the game
biggest look yet sitting in the comment
room the Great Hall is all I care about
Michael says
Nico only time I would care about
sitting is in the Great Hall
Tom it's a yes and no for me if it's not
in the game whatever and as you and as
you kind of encounter different images
sometimes those characters
so each one has kind of like a way to
connect to our games but
um
oh what were they called like the little
uh one of those little things pops up
outside the Hufflepuff area
I agree butter butter beer please what a
great name not being able to sit would
be weird to me
after all the murdering who needs to sit
oh my goodness
throw pumped is R1 appearing over the
objects right right Eskimo yeah yeah
being able to sit is a big deal to open
world RPG Gamers really I feel like I'm
a big open world RPG fan and I just do
not care
in the slightest we could throw chairs
but not sit right right
you're not close enough to it I think we
can sit think we can sit
ready to call Tyrell I'm not sitting in
this game
Rodrigo what I find interesting is that
we can't slot all four diamonds with
four spells to begin with
slot the four with all four to begin
with
what do you mean what do you mean
Rodrigo I see four slotted right here
unplayable if no sitting you could sit
in Skyrim I think
yeah I could throw a chair but not sit
on it
194 likes oh my goodness we got to do a
uh we gotta do a quote
true Heath that was a big animal
crossing fan you do like there is
sitting in uh Animal Crossing
there is sitting in Animal Crossing
oh my gosh Lauren
watch the make a post about sitting
tomorrow
oh my goodness I would lose it you could
sit in Skyrim okay okay see I I
I just don't care I don't care Dr
Sherwood I wish I was you right now more
poet let's let's check in on the poll
over 211 votes at this point 55 of you
care about being able to sit in awkwards
oh this is so good 45 no
oh man
in the PlayStation showcase the Avatar
was sitting on the bed right right when
it first starts you see them like get up
off the bed yeah
students out of bed
oh man guys thank you for all the likes
we're gonna do a Harry Potter I mean
yeah right away when I want to just
covering up Harry Potter okay
there it is so there you go so I really
wonder if this is story mode
and or
will it apply to normal and other
difficulties because
clearly in whatever mode they're playing
right now the the flu flame it shows up
even if you haven't discovered it yet
now I think the question is like how far
out
how close do you have to get you know
for it to pop up
because that that little white icon has
been showing the whole time and then our
character they walks up they walk up to
it Discover it
excuse me
and then it immediately turns green here
and it turns green here too
cheat mode I know it does feel a little
bit it does feel a little bit strange
I'm trying to think of how other games
handle that
I feel like with other like I feel like
they don't just show you the icon right
away
I don't know I'm trying to remember how
it goes to Shima and like
those other open World Games handle it
like Witcher I know there's lots of
icons at all times it's just been so
long since I played thank you guys thank
you for the blessings
thank you thank you
oh Nico with the Super Chat and another
great point this main character sees all
the chess locations maybe they drank a
liquid luck potion and another one to
reveal the icons that's right so Felix
felicis they specifically said
oh now we gotta go looking for that
I'm Gonna Keep playing this on a broom
already but there is something that we
haven't done so far and that is uh
getting on oh wait Amore poet Amore poet
Mori poet
save your save your next comment because
you're going to be freaking out after
this next shot right here you're gonna
be freaking out
Nico thank you for the comment thank you
for the Super Chat
Dev mode that's a good point too yeah
yeah
there it's on dev mode and all that but
to Nico's point the the specific like
function of Felix felicis was to Revere
Revere oh my gosh reveal gear
like I'm pretty sure it says reveal gear
chests on the map for one in-game day
and it looks like they're already
showing up here
that's a good point that's a good good
point
or a division what is up my friend
what is up thank you for the Super Chat
so we tipped in Italians to the
performer but we steal the drink oh my
goodness right
that's too funny yeah we we didn't leave
anything at all for the for the drink
that we just took off the bar there all
right all right this is one of my
favorite Parts Mount
um one of my favorite Onyx hippogriff
here the Onyx hippogriff is our
pre-order bonus oh my god there he just
like pops out of this so good the back
oh wait you can use it as a horsey
horsey comment and that is uh that's
watching on our flying Mount
um we're gonna hop on our Onyx
hippogriff here the Onyx hippogriff is
our pre-order bonus oh my God there's
just like pops out of the the back you
can use it as a horsey I mean a horse
yeah
um as a hippogriff you can you can
totally Allen's like as a hippogriff
oh that's too funny
so differentiation from the brooms right
the fact that you can use it as a
ground-based mount in addition to flight
the legendary horsey Comet right that
will forever live in uh Hogwarts Legacy
lore
forever legendary gamer Society hey
thanks for the Super Chat my friend uh
we will have mirror robes
so we can sit and reflect have mirror
robe
what do you mean mirror robe
we will have mirror robe so we can sit
and reflect
like if there is a uh
post it in the chat legendary Gamers a
clarification
you can use it as a horsey from now on
hippogriffs are now horsies we shall
never acknowledge the old name
oh dude
retro slow down on the pun okay wait
slow down we will have mirror row I mean
I get like mirror and reflect
I get that mirror robe so we can sit and
reflect what
what am I missing guys
sorry legendary gamer sorry
legendary Gamers just like oh face
palming right now
reflect no I I get I get the reef I get
the reflect
but I don't get the connection to
mirrors
I mean
I'm just digging the whole more I get
the connection of mirrors retro way
overthinking this no see I'm thinking
like okay a robe we've got a robe here
it's like an invisibility cloak it's
like made of mirrors we've got a robe
here it's like like the outside of it
it's made of mirrors so we're gonna sit
down and then we're just gonna we're
gonna put the robe around us and it's
gonna be reflecting
because you guys know they've tried to
make real world invisibility cloaks and
that's how they work that's how they
work because it's like a mirrors thing
a room full of mirrors works better I go
there to reflect okay see there all
right all right JP there you go there
you go I can't breathe Jason says
oh my gosh I damaged you with my robes
my aggressive system
foreign
oh wow
we're off the rails now ZZ I'm dying
not that kind wait noobs like yelling
not that kind of reflecting
guys I know there's multiple meanings of
reflecting I know I know
JP put it into very very nice terms
there
legendary Gamers either legendary Gamers
either clicked off the chat forever and
they're never coming back or they're
just like
dying of laughter right now to where
they physically can't type A further
response for us
oh my goodness
oh wait there they are I don't think he
was ready
oh my goodness
yeah yeah it's like newt's case
first Cedric now retro how many Wizards
are turning out to be vampires oh my
gosh
if you want to do it well you have to
bend light not to reflect it for maximum
effect
geez all right all right all right all
right we're moving on from the
reflecting we're moving on from the road
we write it like a ground Mound and you
can lift off into the air sorry I ruined
the joke maybe I I probably made your
joke even better legendary gamer Society
it probably had even more of an effect
than you were anticipating
all right so we get the there's another
creature right there and you can lift
off you guys notice this little Stone
you think that's like Moonstone or
something over there I think it is
I think we see a similar icon in the
room of requirement later it's the air
and we tried to make sure thornback
scurrier
if that's the uh
oh wait that just looks like
yeah I don't think that's what's popping
up right there
each each of those interactions so the
Brand's really good at reaching that top
speed all right so those the little claw
marks are beast dens
I saw um that's confirmed later on in
the room of requirements section
kind of traveling the world as quickly
as possible but sometimes it's really
nice to get on the hip I know yeah you
hear them
as it goes by
the Hornback is the spider on the right
oh I didn't even see a spider so the
into the air um as a
tried to make sure that
oh it's right there I never saw it you
totally write it like a ground Mount and
you can lift up during the day too
look right there
thornback scurrier there it is
oh my gosh I did not see that no Draco
did not see that until right then that's
each dude
that no I know right seeing that cow
brought me so much I know look at him
there's two cows over here and then
listen here let me turn it see this is
why the volume keeps getting loud sorry
I want to turn it up so you guys can
hear this
they ride it like a ground Mount and you
can lift off into the air and we tried
to make sure that each each of those
interactions so the broom's really good
and then you get this little question
mark like counting down
I've seen some people speculating that
this is like a detection thing so like a
stealth kind of when it when it
completely fills then that means you've
been detected by the enemy the spider
going for the call
no Natasha no
no
surely they would not go that far would
they
dude
could you imagine if you're just like if
you just see a spider attacking
attacking the cow no way please no
please no
rip cow reaching that top speed at dude
it does look like it's making it's right
like a Ground Round And you can lift off
into the air and we tried to make sure
that
did you see the cow run though I wonder
if the cow sees us and runs the first
time I saw it I thought they just kind
of get spooked by us flying overhead and
then they take off lift off into the air
and we tried to make sure that each of
those interactions are getting out of
there dude they're getting out of
traveling the world as quickly as
possible but sometimes it's really nice
to get on the hippogriff I wonder if
that Beast Den that we saw back there
the icon I wonder if it's for a bunch of
spiders because of that ground speed or
those transitions uh and sometimes it
just feels amazing just to be riding
around on it
yeah it's it really is kind of like how
much fun I don't know it's a great
feeling just this okay another uh
ancient magic Merlin puzzle popped up
over there on the left got some more
enemies here here on the or on the right
I'm sorry and then more enemies here on
the left
legendary Gamers hey legendary Gamers
didn't leave thank you for not leaving
us legendary Gamers oh my thanks for the
laugh we'll be able to level up
hippogriff so they didn't I don't think
they asked about that
do wonder if we'll be able to get like
different
mounts or anything that's a great
feeling like magazine looks like we're
riding with a saddle or anything from
run to fly and just being able to go
wherever you want and we tried to make
sure that looks like a couple goblins
right there loyalist assassins got those
yeah so I think pretty clearly that
meter is like a detection
slow a loyalist assassin we see that
popping up each one of these things that
you can interact with have have a unique
identity and a reason for it and then I
also wonder like what what's making this
pop up right now
that's part of another reason I think
maybe it's on like the story mode or
something right now the tool wheel is
useful for dealing with higher level
combat situations combat plants and
Potions can give you an advantage
against tougher enemies
I hope so Legendary Legendary
because the difference in the hippogriff
and the thestral and the broom is that
with the the creature mounts they can go
higher but I guess their speed is kind
of set so we don't have that boost over
here on the right so I guess like what
would you be upgrading then
so I'm going to say no probably I'm
going to say no
Heath with a super chat as well hey
thank you so much for the Super Chat for
being part of our community here
thinking loyal to ran Rock good point
good point probably so
probably so
and then Matt jumping in there with a
super chat Matt thank you so much
for the support of the stream train
tracks below we travel by the train to
hogsmeade oh did we just pass that back
up which one of these fun to fly
feelings
oh my gosh dude it's a great feeling
managing those transitions kind of going
from run I wonder if you'll get to see
so the Hogwarts Express I don't think it
run like obviously it's not running all
the time but I wonder if we'll have like
a special scene at Christmas when some
of the students go home for the holidays
if we'll get to like obviously we're our
character is most likely going to be
I mean unless unless they do like a cut
scene or something that'd be kind of
interesting if you went if you went
somewhere
but um
yeah wonderful I actually get to see see
the Train the Hogwarts Express traveling
on here at some point
I hope so
I really hope so now
but yeah thank you for the Super Chat
there and then I saw
being able to ride is the upgrade right
I saw another question I wanted to
respond to
um what a Resto momentum work on people
running or flying uh I mean it should
right
that's not the Hogwarts Express line
Natasha
oh does that one run through a different
different path
all right let's do our uh so we hit 100
likes actually we hit 200 likes thank
you guys so much that helps more people
find our stream
so whatever we do when we hit 100 likes
is we do a random
quote from the Harry Potter series and
see if you guys can uh
see how well you guys can do on Guessing
the Character and the book so while we
do that I'm gonna pull up
oh wait actually let's do the uh let's
do the playlist again because then we
can if you guys don't know about this
like if you ever just want to cycle
these in the background
[Music]
so these are the new common room
fireplace videos they shared so they
have them uploaded as a playlist so if
you just go to youtube.com Hogwarts
Legacy you're a wizard and then you go
to it's like right here at the top you
can hit play all and then if you hit
this little Loop playlist button right
here
that'll get them to just play over and
over and you can also if you wanted to
do like Shuffle so it doesn't go in
order
all right so I'm not giving Slytherin
any more views right now
sorry Chandler
and all my Slytherin friends out there
uh Yago or Yago thank you for
subscribing to the channel
and also Jerry with a super chat Jerry
thanks so much for the Super Chat do you
think swimming and diving's in the game
okay so Jerry we talked a lot about that
on the uh
we did a big live stream on Friday with
a bunch of uh other Hogwarts Legacy
creators
podcast Alex from podcast now invited
several of us on and we answered that
question and I think most people said we
will have swimming but no diving and
that's where I landed too
that's where I landed was swimming but
no diving
uh-oh what happened elwin what happened
I guess he doesn't oh the Slytherin
comment sorry oh wait how did I click on
I didn't mean to click on Ravenclaw
either we're going Gryffindor here
yeah if you guys I was uh we were
commenting earlier on how gryffindors
has more views I'm just saying even
though the official Hogwarts Legacy
account they tweeted out they tweeted
out the Slytherin one but
sorry Chandler sorry man
uh you guys know I'm just giving you a
hard time
you guys know
all right so let's find a this is what
we do whenever we hit 100 likes for
those of you who may be new to the
Stream
all right let's see here um
I have to pull from a different place
each time because I don't want you guys
to
[Music]
oh actually
this would be a good time to do this
I just thought of one I just thought of
a specific one I want to do
all right hold on hold on hold on
[Music]
okay
all right so you get one point if you
get the character correct you get two
points if you can name the book as well
so book and character
points in the Retro reckon tour
imaginary list of
prizes
all right so you guys ready here's the
quote here's the quote
so this is like this is a character
quote from one of the Harry Potter books
and you're not sitting with the prefix
today either
said blank Christmas is a time for
family
here it is again here it is again and
you're not sitting with the prefix today
either said blank Christmas is a time
for family
all right one more time one more time
and you're not sitting with the prefix
today either said blank Christmas is a
time for family hey we got another uh
Professor Baxter with the two months
retro just wanted to say happy to be a
member on your wonderful Channel such a
generous Community think we'll see
godrics Hollow and Hogwarts Legacy I
would love to see godrick's Hollow I
think that'd be a I still like everybody
keeps saying oh they're revealing so
much they're revealing so much and
Chandler's like guys this is the tip of
the iceberg
I don't think I think there's still a
lot more in store
and they if you think about it they
haven't showed anything
about other locations
we saw a brief glimpse of Gringotts
in one of the trailers we know
hogsmead's in we've seen a little bit of
hogsmeade
and I still don't know what to think
about Azkaban man because I think that
was 100 as command in the reveal trailer
then you've got Dementors on the deluxe
cover but then they haven't said
anything else about Dementors we haven't
seen them at all
oh my goodness you guys you know what I
just thought of
later in this video Alan makes a comment
about how
that certain times of day there'll be
specific quests based on the time of day
I wonder
I wonder if the mentors like only come
out at night or in a specific season all
right let's see if you guys got it right
we got Ron we got Ginny
we got uh Natasha says Fred book one
Alicia me in book six that one is
incorrect we got Molly Weasley we got
George we got George book three uh we
got Fred book one definitely a Weasley
Fred or George Fred or George book one
Fred or Georgian the third book
one Georgia Fred first year Fred or
George Weasley Frederick George forget
which Hermione book six Harry Potter
book two Jenny Ron Hermione ordered the
Phoenix Molly Weasley oh we got we got
some uh across the board here oh I
thought I put it on replay there we go
loot playlist
okay lots of Fred and George lots of
Fred and George
attempted to say Molly no I must be
wrong says Wolfie
Christy you nailed it I think some other
people gotten it too yeah so it's George
in book one
it's George in the first book I knew
that would be a little bit tricky
because anytime with the friend with the
twins
it's sometimes hard to remember exactly
which one
I just I was just recently rereading
that whole like Christmas sequence
it's just such a lovely chapter
just such a lovely chapter like the best
Christmas of Harry's like he wasn't even
really looking forward to Christmas he
talks about how he was looking forward
to the food
because he knew they would have some
good food but he wasn't even thinking
that he would have gifts and all this
and then how the the Weasleys just like
hate the family sweaters and Harry's so
touched by it such a good chapter man
so congrats for those of you who got
both of them correct
Jason says we'll be sentenced to ask man
I
I can't say I definitely feel like we're
going to ask Bam but I do feel like
we're gonna see ask man at some point I
feel like at some point
Chrissy you're reading them for the
first time oh my goodness
now that would be to be able to re-read
them again for the first time oh my
goodness
on that one right now Ravenclaw Tyrell
nice
hey Shadow guided it is late or early
depending on how you look at it all good
thank you for being here have a good
night
Kevin hope we get to choose our wand so
Kevin I don't know if you saw they they
have where you can link your Wizarding
World Fan Club account so if you are if
you want to it's optional but if you
have the Wizarding World test set up
like they do a whole little test you can
get your wand on there
it will carry over into into the game
they've confirmed that
um as for how it will actually work if
you don't do that they haven't really
said a lot about that yet so
so it remains to be seen
never read them only seen the movies oh
the books are so good
they're so good
yog I thought about that too
I don't think it confirms it but it
certainly made me think about that too
[Music]
it certainly made me think about that
uh for those of you who didn't see or
maybe just listening they asked does
broom customization confirm that we will
also get one customization I'm gonna
stop short of saying confirmed
but I I pointed notice how I pointed out
that they keep talking about Cosmetics
Cosmetics like if you can change the
Cosmetic of it
but then you're like like the Utility
side of it the function in the game is
controlled by some other sort of upgrade
so I could definitely see them doing
that with wands as well
I almost feel like they that's that's
been such a big fan request and that's
the thing that you already know because
they have the account linking you
already know it's in the game it's like
you already know multiple types of Wands
are in the game it's just the
customization aspect we don't know about
it we have have a unique identity and a
reason for being
and oh my God like I see like different
like areas like Swamp People and then
this whole area gets really strange what
do you guys think about this symbol
they clearly stop here they want us they
want us to look at this one also
levitate a dug bog by its tongue
what
what
have my account linked I'm you're
worried about what your cherry one will
look like I'm pretty sure you'll be able
to change it Draco even if you don't
like it I'm pretty sure yeah by the way
can you go to like entirely oh there's
regions there are optional yeah
there's kind of a moment where the world
kind of opens up to you outside it's a
big point right here
early on in the game I mean I feel like
this symbol right here is
like ancient magic related
some sort of puzzle but it's not it's
not one of the Merlin puzzles those have
the little leaf instead
uh some of you were asking my wand it is
a phoenix core
I always forget the uh
it is Phoenix core
hold on I'm pulling it up over here
Beach Beachwood Beachwood Phoenix core
12 and 1 4 unbending flexibility
foreign
there you go
the true match for a beach one will be
if Young wise Beyond his or her years
and a full-grown rich and understanding
and experience
performed very weakly for the
narrow-minded and intolerant such
Wizards and witches having obtained a
beach wand without having been suitably
matched yet coveting this most desirable
richly hewed and highly prized wandwood
having often presented themselves at the
homes of learned wand makers
or learn it I think is how you say it
um when it's used in that context such
as myself demanding to know the reason
for their handsome wands lack of power
when properly matched the beach one is
capable of a subtlety and Artistry
rarely seen in any other wood hence its
lustrous reputation
yep so that's that's mine but yeah
what do you guys think about this one
right here
what do you guys think about that one
oh did we get another we got another
Super Chat Dustin hey thank you Dustin
all the armor in the loom are upgradable
for defense wands will have charms up
will they have offense too Dustin
I was just rev looking over that for a
video we might make it to that point in
this we're only 7 40 in I don't know we
might have to break down more next week
too
um but I'm pretty sure they have offense
as well hold on let me just skip to that
so we need to jump back to 7 40.
but just since since Dustin came in with
the Super Chat there
I was just looking at that section
yeah so right here over on the right
offense defense
and they they talk about it a little bit
too in that section
but that is an interesting idea if if
the wands are instead charms for offense
some of you are saying this looks like a
labyrinth swamp reminds me of Eldon ring
I know like the whole the whole scene
just early on everything shifts when
they get into this little area right
here I agree with the Labyrinth yeah as
soon as as soon as you let's take a
closer moments
I was wondering what that was over there
hold on we got distracted oh there's
like lock from you yeah it cuts away
from this one quick but like there's
uh just looks like some more rock
formations maybe a little lamp post
there kind of lighting this path there's
kind of a moment where the world kind of
opens up to you outside of Hogwarts and
they fly right right early on in the
game you can I don't I don't see
anything side of Hogwarts really
different it's this little Archway right
here
so maybe you pass through that Archway
and then some sort of maze appears
all right let's end our poll question
goodness gracious we had 353 votes do
you care about being able to sit our
final tally guys 57 yes they care about
being able to sit in Hogwarts Legacy
oh that's too funny
all right guys well for for your sake I
hope we get it I hope we get it
I really do
um
Antoine when am I getting invited to one
of those showcases
I can't answer this question Antoine not
because I'm under NDA but because no
matter how I answer this people
immediately say it's you yeah I knew it
we were when we were on with uh the
whole crew Friday people were asking we
were trying to figure out who it like
because I mean could it be someone in
that group yeah you know
if they're even doing a third but yeah
everybody was trying to like I I haven't
been contacted so no I'm I'm not under
I'm not under any NDA
I told Chad what to look for though like
if you ever hear
I shouldn't even say it but if you if
I'm ever like if I just straight up
ignore it or I'm like well I can't say
or
then then everybody in here you all have
heard me talk enough would be like oh
it's it's yes they're doing one but no
no I haven't I haven't heard anything
all right see there we go we know it's
you it's you it's you that was a long
vote I know sorry I forgot I just left
it up for a while
in one of the videos we uh our
characters almost submerged in water if
we can't swim it seems weird yeah
everybody was saying if we're talking
about in the trailer I don't think
that's water I think that's like a like
a fog like a dense fog if it's the video
I'm thinking about
maybe it's a portal oh that's
interesting like you walk through and
then all of a sudden you get like a or
maybe it transports you to somewhere
completely different
but yeah it definitely looks like some
sort of Puzzle maze Labyrinth type area
it's just you don't see any of that when
they fly over early on in the game you
can go wherever you want and so you
might find more difficult challenges in
different areas and you'll see different
spots
uh what are you talking about Wolfie
Wolfie said retro come on oh let's be
honest I'm being honest
I wonder if you're under if you're under
NDA can you say I'm not I guess you can
I guess you could say that
but I'm not I'm really not
uh people really admire I appreciate
that Ravenclaw Tyrell and yeah I have I
mean I have seen all the comments of
people saying they they hope I get to do
one and they they'd love to see me up
there so I definitely I definitely see
them and I definitely appreciate that so
it means a lot that you guys think I
would
I would do a good job there was a Reddit
poll the P the Harry Potter game
subreddit they had a poll like who
should be the next guest
like I'll click on this
so yeah it means a lot guys I appreciate
it
feather hey feathers how's it going uh
how the chair is highlighted what if we
can conjure and modify things outside
the room of requirement
oh I no way no way
no way I can't even let my mind go there
because of how insane that would be like
almost like a dreams Minecraft type
thing could you imagine like maybe it's
an in-game thing they're like oh you can
customize the whole world now I can't
even I can't even go there feathers I
can't even go there
but that would be awesome
that is true dark lord Aeron Sue is on
the work trip indeed
indeed
portal to the tri-wizard maze I know it
did kind of make me think about the
tri-wizard
guesses wizard PhD that's who I guess
Jenny I said ER but then Andy I don't
know Andy was saying some stuff on our
live stream
he was trying so hard to get James and
Ben to say stuff
I was like hmm you're talking awful lot
about ndas Andy maybe you just signed an
NDA
oh my Wizards
says Andrew's moving around like an area
that's plagued with dark magic yeah
like a coast and we've got different
types of Dustin gonna spam with at least
one Super Chat a week ask me about
another showcase Dustin wants to see if
I'll ever just all those things exist
stop answering it you guys would know
it's like so rustic like I keep
forgetting that this is like 1800s The
Wizarding World would never really sing
before like customers like it just I
think so no one I do I do we were just
talking about how you can link your
Wizarding World account if you didn't
have to do that you know for sure that
those ones that are on Wizarding World
are in the game I want you to see what
this world looks like so I think so I
think there would be some customizations
that's been a big request for a while
[Music]
big request for a while
sparkly patch below as they fly through
the swamp around 7 43.
hold up hold up wherever you want
and so you might find oh yes difficult
challenge good catch and nothing on the
map for that one
good catch so I wonder if that's part of
the maze oh you know it could be like
those mazes in Eldon rate well they're
not really mazes but like like like a
little thing appears and then you have
to like go and find where the next one
appears then you have to go find the
next one and maybe it eventually leads
to you be able to unlock whatever
challenges in different areas and you'll
see different spots as Andrew's moving
around like you mentioned the swamp
um
types of environments I haven't signed
anything just to kind of uh pepper
everywhere it is just making me more
sure see there you go all those things
exist there you go I just okay I love
that windmill see here we go here we go
uh Dustin from now on we will not be
talking anymore we never really seen
before like it feels so authentic like
it just it's part of it yeah I I love it
too and change the I'm gonna have Andrew
stop here we're gonna use a bit of thank
you Antoine I appreciate that change the
seasons actually I want to see we have
trust issue she's from James's work trip
I know right I kept telling James that
too
if you go to the 46 minute Mark gameplay
showcase a month ago 1926 when they're
walking down the steps circular icon
when they're at the fountain Heath
inside Hogwarts right yeah I commented
on that in your uh in in your in my
video about
uh the breakdown of that one I did
EFA Spartan Andy reloads went dark and
James welcomed him back before
mysterious
ah he did go dark for a bit
kind of like how Ben went dark for a bit
I said Andy because they showed a
Slytherin at the end
of the last one
that's that's what I said
retrohydrate if you haven't signed an
NDA
hydrate if you haven't okay
there we go there we go guys there you
have it
foreign
ask Alex oh who all he has to be on the
stream and was too busy to be there
you guys are trying to get to the bottom
of this
uh I think so Draco yeah yeah I think
they probably would
don't breathe if you have signed an NDA
don't don't breathe okay I'm still
breathing Michael I'm still breathing
hold on I want to see feather feathers
had a comment about
um
something about slottable
where'd it go
I don't know why the chat goes by too
fat too fast sometimes Tyler hey thank
you Tyler for the Super Chat retro
Heather Theory I think the blue dash is
for the good landscape good path
completely in the book with the black
fog is the darkness actually and is
Merlin the same Merlin that helped the
Knights of the Round Table or not okay
so great question Tyler in all the
discussion about Merlin James has
probably touched on this at some point
so the Merlin of the Harry Potter series
is a bit different from the traditional
Merlin of
Arthurian Legend it's a little bit
different because he lived much later
the Merlin in the Harry Potter series
actually came after
the founders of Hogwarts
um
and went attended Hogwarts and was a
Slytherin is like the story in the Harry
Potter World
I don't know if Joe ever like clarified
it more than that
I don't know but then I don't know like
I don't know any of you in the chat know
about the whole like Arthurian lore and
Legend like when that was supposed to be
could definitely mess with ever I mean
I've I have Johnny I have stopped
replying a lot of people reach out on
Twitter and say you're the next showcase
aren't you or I hope you are
some of them all heart but I've just
stopped commenting because I'm like
uh yeah we use it no we'll use it as a
narrative marker through through the
game so as you're progressing through
your main storyline it was important for
us to kind of like have those moments
that kind of yoga I used to watch the
movies where you know you'll see kind of
like the title cards I'll say yes and
I'll say yes that you can fall off and
you're really feeling those that passage
of time maybe even cast the rest of
momentum that'd be hilarious and I think
oh wait did it just discover that
did it discover that flu flame Oh I
thought okay so it's white here but it's
green over here so they they must have
already discovered that one
uh dream and plays games with the super
chat right there oh sorry I missed it
because it was right after Tyler bought
streaming plays games thank you for the
Super Chat great uh got work in the am
gonna head out leave this here thanks
for the stream retro hey dreaming thank
you for stopping by hanging out and
thank you for the Super Chat hope you
have a good day at work tomorrow uh
Leisure not with the five dollar Super
Chat believe it or not thank you for
your support good to see you here
tonight uh Ben Snow's hop off the
character in his Showcase with us still
there and that's right they did show a
lot of but the character they start off
with
oh wait we don't know what they are do
we because they're wearing
I thought they were helping you
particularly because they ended James's
showcase yeah I'm uh I'm showing a
different character hop on the Broom
yeah
so they're purely cosmetic but the room
is green if you talk to the shopkeeper
I'll continue with this holidays or
things like that where hogs me oh hold
on that's a big part gameplay impact
like I'm gonna let it play for bits so
you guys can or does it like it's just
the weather of Scotland uh yeah we use
it we really Ben asked another great
question here about like is it is it
just like purely visual the the changes
of the scenery by the way this over here
use it as a narrative marker through
through the game looks to me like some
sort of Arena so as you notice nothing
like look at all this something is going
on over here no icons
earlier we had icons everywhere I mean
storyline it was important for us
yeah definitely a lot to explore there
and then we also had uh Antoine with a
super chat
777 Lucky Sevens for you happy holidays
keep doing you man it got my support
love your chill and genuine Vibes hey
Antoine thank you my friend
thank you thank you for the Super Chat
and thank you for uh hanging out
supporting all the content very much
appreciated and then right after that
elwin with another Super Chat thank you
Elwyn did you hear the theory Ben James
and chat came up with at the title of
the game
is not our Legacy at Hogwarts but the
legacy of Hogwarts itself I was there
for that part yes
yes when they both kind of uh lost their
minds that was pretty great and now the
landscape is changing it I like the
feeling those that passage of time if
you remember from the very first reveal
trailer the narrator says like for me
it's really fun it says like you're the
choices
within the school as well so and see
here's where they they like they teased
they get so close to the water with the
hippogriff so close which I I agree I
think I can't believe we've spent like
that's within the schools
we're at the two and a half hour mark we
haven't even made it past the first
little there's another one of those
little glowing areas by the way the
school reacts we haven't even made it
past the first section you guys that
really helped just kind of make me feel
like I'm there we're definitely gonna
have to split this up it's not just you
know for the seasons
I was hoping to record a video after the
stream tonight cycle even though
similarly like it's largely about Vibe
when you go into hogsmeade in the
evening there's less characters there
around 850 the player character says
this could prove dangerous winners just
can't believe oh wait new new icon new
icon
you know similarly hold up guys watch
watch right here in the middle like it's
largely about five when you go into
hogsmeade in the evening there it is and
there's like two
there's a skull right here and then a
smaller skull behind it and then a
detection so I'm gonna guess that these
are the wizard poachers is my guess the
guy the skull guys the guys with the
skull masks that we've seen in some of
the trailers
meet in the evening there's less
character man it goes by so fast oh
didn't mean to do that
I'm trying to see if we can catch a
glimpse of any of this
like you get a little bit of the like a
maybe like a bandit camp or something
uh Jonathan a one-year game in Hogwarts
I'm thinking it's one year yeah I'm
thinking one year
uh botfly thank you for the
clarification yeah I was thinking that
the founders were supposed to be much
later yeah Arthurian Legend from the 5th
6th and 6th Century Founders are
theorized to be from the 10th century
by the way Carl thank you for
subscribing to the channel and then
fueled by the fire with another Super
Chat thank you for the support uh that's
not a flu flame it's the ancient magic
oh wait did I miss did I misspoke on
that the one just from a little bit ago
that was like on the
make me feel holidays and you see the
decorations around those environments
change
um that really helped just confirmed uh
holiday decorations by the way by Alan
and you guys heard that as I was talking
over it earlier before the seasons those
those kind of vibe things
um like we have a day night cycle and
that day night cycle even though it's
definitely like it's largely about Vibe
when you go into hogsmeat in the evening
there's less characters there around the
school who knows it kind of dies down
and quiets down just I mean there's just
Candlelight and students kind of like as
you're walking through the Halls you say
something else but in that day night
cycle is where we've kind of placed a
few items where you know whether or not
you can collect them or whether or not
you can interact with them with that are
a little bit restricted by the day night
cycle
so basically what that means is there's
going to be certain quests
maybe even certain NPCs that you
interact with when it's it has to be day
or night to be able to do it
I love that love that
my screen just flickered here for a
second
wait what was that noise
further back there were like no icons
around oh yeah yeah I was trying
to actually this is what happens man I
get so sidetracked because there's so
much gameplay impact like I know exactly
this is like you can't look at anything
until we uh it's part of it get what
really what I was talking about here
it's after the snow change right though
it was after the snow it changes a
little like gameplay of Scotland uh yeah
we use it we really use it narrative
marker through through the game so as
you're progressing through your main
storyline I was talking about that
little area over there have those
moments that kind of felt like when
you're reading oh you're right it's not
a flu flame good catch my fault my fault
yeah that is totally the ancient magic
symbol so we have
dude we've got like the um Merlin
puzzles
we thought those were the ancient magic
stuff
we thought those were the ancient magic
now we have one that's specific to
ancient magic here
we've got the other like puzzle
Labyrinth like one
go ninja go thank you for the Super Chat
my friend Merry Christmas guys only
Channel member Channel I'm a member of
wanted to spread some cheers just got
home from work saw my mom snuck in and
decorated my new house yo let's go
my mom loves to decorate too she always
helps decorate our house quite a bit she
does quite a bit of our decorating she
loves that stuff
she gets really really into it
feel by the fire I've said from the
beginning the leaf ones weren't ancient
magic has somebody told James
uh good questions but I feel like if
they're going to have missions set
in that regard I feel like we'll have to
be able to somehow
I feel like we'll have to
watch The Deep dive after April what do
you mean Lauren the Deep dive
reading the books are watching the
movies where you know you'll see kind of
like the title card winter and now the
landscape is changing we it's been two
and a half hours we at least have to get
through the open world scene we got more
cows over here and you're really feeling
those these little balloons here I think
are tied to the uh
the Yum like broom flight challenges yo
Tyler another Super Chat thank you my
friend thank you for clearing that up
the great content off to
Kip is that a UK thing that I don't know
what it means does that mean like sleep
3 20 a.m in the UK
oh Tyler thank you for the support and
thank you for hanging out
yeah no problem dude no problem
but yeah I didn't even we need to I get
back to your previous Super Chat though
Tyler I didn't get a chance to talk
about it
I have a theory that the blue dash is
for the good path
wait did I just completely miss that oh
my gosh Tyler I'm so sorry dude I'm so
sorry
we did answer about the Knights of the
Round Table but then I completely
skipped over your first part there
I think you're right about that because
and I think Alan even confirmed it later
in this gameplay showcase When Alan is
talking with Ben about the combat he
talks about different styles because
they've been showing an awful lot of the
dark side of the unforgivable curses and
in this showcase the ancient magic we
see
two of them just outright like
obliterate people like they just like
vanish one of them it makes them vanish
into like this like black sort of smoky
substance another one it's almost like
they're combusting there's like some
Flames some Sparks going on and then the
other one is when they turn into a
chicken but uh Alan did confirm that the
dash ability is like ancient magic stuff
as well yeah yeah so good call and sorry
I didn't respond to that before now the
first part I just
locked in on the second part of your
question
uh Draco with another Super Chat as well
when they are in the room of requirement
you can see an icon for Conjuring
holiday decorations oh good catch
good catch so I guess when you're in
there you'll be able to set it up uh
yourself
and how you want to do it
oh my gosh Chris
with the Super Chat somebody asked this
on one of James's live streams going
through your year I can't believe it
took you all this long to ask me to I
think it's really fun but it's not just
on the outside which all right so here's
here's the question from Chris guys
snog Mary Avada
options are expecto
Andy and podcast now oh my gosh that is
too funny okay so James already said he
would marry me you know so I think I
think I gotta return the favor I think I
think I gotta return the favor and and
Mary James as well so
I'm I met Sue virtually for the first
time when we did the uh James and I kind
of co-streamed the game awards together
and the fur like the first thing I said
to her like Sue I was I was nervous to
meet you I heard what James said I hope
I hope nothing's going to be awkward
between us
so now I mean my goodness you guys
you're just trying to make it so awkward
between Sue and I and then I'll I'll
snog uh Andy and podcast now I'm not
gonna AK any of those guys I can't do
that I can't I can't make that choice
Chris
so
oh man
you're in trouble retro oh no Sue's not
gonna be happy
she's not gonna be happy Lauren I don't
like God I mean
I'm happily married guys I'm happily
married it's all in good fun it's all in
good fun
just want to swim with the giant squid I
mean we see the giant squid on the uh
the cover of the article
um but within the school as well so
until Rachel's wife I know she watched
she's like sneaky streams
and she'll just like pop into the chat
animations around those environments
change
um that really helps
and it's not just uh oh my gosh fueled
by the fire says
what come on no love for our fellow our
fellow Hogwarts Legacy creators
um DLC thoughts Christian gamer I think
those shoes for sure like we have a day
night cycle and that day night cycle I
think there's so many opportunities for
like some story DLCs meet in the evening
there's less like something that happens
in the summer who knows it kind of dies
down and quiets down yeah so I don't
know what like there's that skull icon
again my guess right now is the poachers
kind of like since you're walking
through the Halls
but okay here's the here's the scene
everybody's freaking out about
on Twitter
everybody's freaking out about this shot
right here because we've been all this
talk about water right
so if you look right here those are kind
of dies down so we're there's a little
like a little stream river running
through
yeah I guess more of a river not a
stream
and so we see we see a red icon over
here so we know we've established
throughout this showcase that we see the
little red icons for
hostile creatures
and we see one right here and then watch
this we're going to see another one
right here in the water
in the water
and also this one's really hard to see
especially if that's kind of scaled down
a bit for you guys and I'm pretty sure
the stream is in 1080. but if you
actually pull up the official Hogwarts
Legacy video here and you watch the 4K
one look in this area and you'll see
like some sort of little Shadow so I'm
gonna back up I mean there's just
candlelights right in that area right
there it is oh dude that that is totally
it's totally something
it is 100 a water creature
look at that dude
I don't know how well it's it's showing
up on stream
I don't know how well it's showing up it
almost looks like exactly like it just
looks like a fish would it would a
regular I mean it looks like a pretty
large fish though
what are the uh oh man I should I used
to have my Fantastic Beasts book right
beside me what are the aquatic creatures
that look like you see nothing wolfy
it's it's right here
it's right here can you guys yeah you
guys see my mouse
it almost looks like a dark greenish
gray color here's like the tail right
here
's the mouth
and then you see the red indicator so
whatever that is right there is a
hostile creature 100 percent
100 and it is definitely a water-based
creature
still I don't think that confirms that
we can go
underwater but it just might come pretty
close to confirming that way can go in
water all right so if you're not seeing
it it almost is easier to see in motion
because you can actually see it kind of
swimming and moving so watch here I'll
play it one more time well you'll notice
it kind of dies down and quiets down
just when you're ready you're ready and
students kind of like there he goes it's
right at the very bottom you can just
see see it just start to swim away but
in that day night cycle it's just
starting to swim away a few items where
Kelpie whether or not you can collect
them or whether or not you can interact
with them that are a little bit
restricted by the day night cycle
and I love Andrew's flying fish from
here
we could slow it down but I don't think
it's gonna be I don't think that's gonna
help any because a few I
fights down just like the way the frames
work around the school you'll notice it
kind of dies down and quiets down just
all right
maybe it'll help because you guys will
get to see it in motion a little bit
okay right there it is right there it is
right there it is I'm tracking tracking
tracking there it goes there it goes
swimming
we'll do it it we'll do it again in slow
without my mouse in the way
it's easier if you pull it up like if
you pull it up on a like I'm looking at
on a 20 27 inch monitor so if you guys
have a
a big size phone or like an iPad or
a bigger screen and you pull up the 4K
version so go to the official Hogwarts
Legacy page 4K version
and it's a lot easier to see because
when we were the person that shared it
with me shared it on Twitter and I was
like
the Twitter compression on videos is so
they're so heavily compressed I couldn't
see anything at all a little bit
restricted by the day night cycle you
see it better in slow mode flying up
here really high up on the hippogriff
and and we're just looking at this view
of Hogwarts in the distance it's just
absolutely beautiful it's part of what I
love most about flying around in this
game whether it's on a hipper Windows
that's it all right I mean you talk
about going anywhere and things that you
can see in the distance and that's one
of my I I still can't get over like I
don't think it looks like a kelp so much
but it's definitely getting more I can
see Hogwarts out there and there's just
done something beautiful about knowing
that all of all of the things inside of
it the classrooms the students the
professors all the places I can go I can
just fly my hippogriff land in the
courtyard enter the front doors and just
walk you know to the library to class or
two Greenhouse or to my common room
but then again does it really look like
this dude either
doesn't really look like that
not really but we're also flying and
looking at a very small
oh here's one in Newt scamander okay so
that's what
oh that's hard to see but that's what
one looks like in the movies
I could see that I mean and of course
they could interpret it slightly
differently too if they wanted to
all right we're almost through this
section guys contiguous and just kind of
like one one space is still exciting to
me after all this I mean I'm just just
I'm speechless right now just absolutely
beautiful which is as much as we want to
spend a lot more time out here just
flying and then another right before
they cut away
another Leaf puzzle right there
could be a dug bog are they
are they underwater
they're like they it did have a pop-up
for them in the uh
swampy area
oh it could I think it's him dude yes
yes let's see do we have any other
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
I don't know how accurate these are to
like Harry Potter but
oh that's kind of cool that's from the
HP lexicon
some artwork they have of a dug bog
that's how you say it right just like a
Doug bog
flying around experiencing two and a
half hours uh I think it was a great
opportunity to well we started off we
did cover some other things we did cover
some other things to start a little bit
of housekeeping saying but uh I think we
did spend a full two hours on just this
little section I think we did
I really think we did and we still
probably missed enter the front doors
and just walk you know to the library to
class or two Greenhouse or to my car
yeah so you get it you get a little bit
of pop in right here like watch the
creatures just kind of up here walk you
know to the library to classrooms into
my common room that it's all contiguous
and just kind of like one so hopefully
those are some of the things I mean I'm
just just I'm speechless right now it's
just absolutely beautiful did we ever go
to the wait a lot more time out here
just flying around dude I bet the yellow
is Hogwarts experiencing the world uh I
think this is a great opportunity I bet
the yellow is Hogwarts we've been
wondering this whole time about here I
was flying around now I want to go back
to the beginning and see if it's down
kind of closer to the ground and as you
raise into the air you'll notice the
meter come out here and take off on your
[ __ ] out of the
our last gameplay showcase just outside
Hogwarts which I love that we can you
can walk out of the castle after walking
or maybe it's like the maybe that's the
icon is which
is for the exact entrance I love that we
can you can walk out of the castle it's
right there it's on our walking through
everything and it does look pretty cool
I'm here and take off on your broom out
into the open world and Alan I know
that's something that you particularly
like about Hogwarts Legacy too yeah
because it's just a random Mark I'm a
big fan of just making yeah that's what
I was thinking at first you can go
anywhere is that it's just amazing
sensation of of everything being open to
you and just Dylan what's up dude get
the things I love flying close to the
ground oh they don't fly that way and
yeah just I love the proximity all right
well chat I mean my intention tonight
was to go through the whole showcase
that kind of felt like when you're
reading the books or watching the movies
where you know you'll see kind of like I
should have known we wouldn't be able to
do that now the landscape has changed
and you're really feeling those that so
those the balloons are for the race yeah
like the broom challenge yeah and I
think I think we wanted to duplicate
that and for me it's really fun that
it's not just on the outside which which
I I agree I think we're really beautiful
um but with in the school as well so
then and I love Andrew I mean that's
like it's definitely dead on in the
direction of and and Hogwarts just
looking at this view of Hogwarts in the
distance it's also right in the
direction of what I love so it could be
the main quest line I feel like that's a
good or a good thought no or maybe
Hogwarts on there at all time distance
and that's one of my I I still can't get
over like no matter I play this so much
but I still I still can't get over the
fact that I can see Hogwarts out there
and there's just something beautiful
about knowing that all of all of the
things
I can just fly my hippogriff land oh
when you're when you're first on the
Broom another water indicator you know
to the library to class or two
Greenhouse or two my comments do you
actually see that one in the water too
Johnny Yes
I mean I'm just just Timothy ninja you
haven't seen it yet oh my gosh it was so
much as much so much more time out here
just fly lying around experiencing the
world honestly like these are my
favorite kind of streams to do you guys
these are my favorite kind of like these
deep Dives
because when I watch it live
there's always a you know I talk some I
wanna obviously I'm gonna react but I
don't want to stop it constantly this is
my favorite when we can really break it
down we have too much fun here to get
through it all I guess that's a good
that's a good and bad thing Wolfie
mostly a good thing though
mostly a good thing
this is a great opportunity to switch
over to combat and last time we gave you
kind of remind you that this time we're
gonna really yeah Lauren people were
asking that earlier I'm going to say
using the dark arts battle arena which
is part of our deal I'm gonna say yes
all right Andrew we got 258 likes yo
let's go is that did we make that
official L win I feel like you and Nico
and the mods are trying to make that
official
that I do an impression when we hit 200.
I don't know if we ever actually said
that
but maybe I did you know what I trust
you guys maybe I did all right so let's
think of a
oh dude I did have the book pulled up I
did have the book pulled up
let me see here let me see
go right back in
I want to do Hagrid that's who I want to
do
let's let's find something to do hagger
so when we hit 100 likes you guys we do
uh we do a random quote from the Harry
Potter series
and when we hit 200 we'd been looking
for something something fun we could do
whenever we hit 200 and I think I may
have said one time like oh what if I did
an impression at 200. I see I feel I
think the problem with this one is I
feel like it'll run out pretty quick
Owen
so I feel like we could do it for now
but I think I'll eventually hit a point
where it's like we're just redoing the
same Impressions all right here we go
keeper of keys
all right let's find a good line from
our buddy Hagrid did I do Hagrid the
last time I think I might have done
Haggard last time
oh Rodrigo hold on 258 a dug bog
crossing the river
oh my gosh you guys are gonna make me
stream like foreign
oh over here on the hold on over here on
the left
so we have uh stop in Hog's meat
actually I don't know if I should be
should I be looking at the map or should
I be looking at the water Rodrigo watch
more than 10 YouTube reactions to the
Showcase already nice
we do not know that three Hillary
Brothers a great question great question
When Alan says I play this game so much
you can see an NPC cast lumos
what
oh my goodness
turn to page 394.
foreign
oh Dobby's a good pick
Dobby is a good pick
uh Heath oh Heath's in a Super Chat
oh my gosh I'm it was two minutes ago
but I still feel bad if it goes by for
more than like a minute and I miss it he
thank you so much for the Super Chat go
to the 46 minute gameplay Showcase from
a month ago at 1926 players walking you
can see an icon on the seats ahead
briefly sitting oh didn't somebody say
that earlier was it you Heath
I'm sorry yeah yeah so I pointed that
out in another video but yeah we'll try
it we'll try to check that before we hop
off here Dustin you have to practice off
camera with more impression so we don't
run out right but even if I do that like
I'm just like in the Harry Potter
universe
I mean at some point we'll be down to
like Rookwood you know
all right hold on let me think of my
favorite my favorite Dobby quote here
didn't we do Dobby before
oh no it was 100
sorry I'm just going back and seeing
everybody saying it's 100 official
all right we got a Dobby we got a Dobby
grop oh my goodness grop would be hard
Luna Lovegood
you also get to 300 in this stream and
need something to do and so oh my
goodness variety of different brooms and
it was important to us you didn't say
The Impressions had to be good
Hermione if you need material oh I could
do some good I shouldn't say good I
could do some funny Hermione ones
and those those upgrades will make it so
that we're normal all right we got a
snake we can only fly I feel like we
either we either did Hagrid or Dobby
before you can only go at Max Speed
somebody just tell me who we did before
kind of close and then I'll pick one of
those into the air you'll notice the
meter drop and so it goes up or if we
didn't do either I feel like we did that
distance from the ground and there we've
obviously done Ollivander Ollivander is
my go-to for any of you new to the
stream elevator is my go-to Logan
they're endless quote they're endless
quotes but like characters like there
are only so many voices that mechanic
encourage so many voices that we would
even know how to do right it's not just
a travel like the tree you get the trio
you get the professors you get the Death
Eaters you get the Weasleys I really
love doing but as well maybe some
Ministry folks explore on the ground and
so kind of keeping you down at the
ground to me it feels like it's got this
kind of Surfing Vibe over there like I'm
just like I want to see you guys are
just throwing out everybody mountains of
the forest enter that Hamlet
oh I'm doing Alicia's just because I
love this one all right
is that the exact quote Alicia or is
there something before that
all right I actually can do a pretty
decent Dobby but I've never done this
slime before so let's see here all right
Dolby never meant to murder he only
meant to maim or seriously Ninja
so that normal Dobby quote is um
master wait no no no
he is free
you got to get that like kind of crack
in the boy
right there at the end
oh there we go there we go
wonderful wonderful one of those
represent gameplay in I feel like I did
Dobby before but I'm cool
challenges or different secrets that
exist
um as soon as I saw Alicia's I was like
I have to do you'll notice that I love
the line
as well so when you go out in the open
world and you see those icons whether
they're on so good or on your map or off
in the distance those things are
opportunities to say like I want to
increase my inventory you guys are
giving me some other good ones though
next time
we do hacker all the time whenever I
hear it or learn about your ancient
magic and Marco thank you for
subscribing to the channel enemies and
then do we get Dustin oh yeah all right
so Heath before we go Keith said so
let's go to the other gameplay showcase
um at the 1926
all right so gameplay showcase
1926 here
on Central Station
yes so yeah this is the one that I
commented on in the video that I made
correction you know and I I did I took
it as being a sitting icon as well right
right there
so we had that we had the big
conversation about sitting earlier you
guys big conversation Transfiguration
court right there it is
and I feel like that like I feel like
that one is clearly saying hey I mean
what else would it be right maybe you
interact you do something to interact
with the fountain
um but yeah I think that one because you
already see the student other students
sitting right here so I could totally
see this being like yeah just go ahead
and have a seat right there buddy you
know the library Straight Ahead says yo
Kelly thank you for subscribing or no
becoming a member Kelly you are
officially a new member of House rack
and tour
thank you thank you
really good quotes yes
there's a lot of good mad-eye Moody
quotes
yeah she was get really good for
Bellatrix
they do sit by the fountain yeah yeah
right Christy that's so our character
never sits but you can definitely see
the others
clearly sitting there
oh no see I got all Draco I never saw
the dug bug
I never saw the other one
what was the timing again on it and then
let me know if I need to be looking at
the uh
if I need to be looking at the
map or if I need to be looking at the
water right cycle wow and I love Andrews
flying up here really high up on the
hippogriff and and we're just we're
members the God of War Hammer I know for
the new house members I moved it I need
to uh
let's see if I can uh
you guys can see it so like you you all
can see my my little board right here I
know you can't see it the full but above
that I have like a little Shelf
and so my kids kept trying to get the
hammer out playing with it so I put it
up there on the Shelf
so it's up there on the shelf for now
but yeah I do usually uh
I need to just start getting it down
before each stream but I think after uh
I think after Christmas once I take the
tree down the hammer will have a
permanent spot back here somewhere
back here most likely
with some of our other little uh other
little goodies
but thank you for the Super Chat Dustin
very much appreciated Kelly with a super
chat as well love all of you guys who
have covered this just want to share the
love Kelly thank you so much for the
love for for donating for becoming a
member here enjoy enjoy the emotes you
can use those when you're uh in the live
stream which you can also use them on
any of our videos so if you comment in
videos you can use them there as well
all right I'm looking for I'm looking
for draco's post here to let me know
to let me know where to find
training for the ballet Potter see you
guys are gonna get me doing them just
like oh
just reading and repeating another good
one Wolfie another good one they said
250 oh yeah 258 feathers thank you
feathers okay I thought it was early
yeah
all right so I don't know if I need to
be looking at brings me actually a broom
shop and so and let's go ahead and just
slow it down like we did earlier
I see rocks rocks rocks
is that uh that looks just like a rock
to me
more rocks I mean then right there at
the last second I do see this red up
here
in the in the water
definitely not as obvious as the other
one at least if it's been here yet
on the far left
let me rewind it again
all right so far left far left
I'm not seeing it
I'm not giving up though I'm not giving
up
yeah I see the indicator for sure for
sure I see the red indicator that shows
up
that looks like a rock
let me go check don't see why they
wouldn't have some type of sea creatures
yeah I think so Kelly well the other one
I mean it's pretty clear in that other
shot you wouldn't 100 see a creature
swimming in the water and it pops up the
little red indicator but I'm not sure
I'm not sure the one here the narrow
part also up here
oh that right there
that is exactly where the red
is located
oh I think you nailed it
I think you nailed it it's not moving
though I don't see it move at all like I
could totally just mistake that for a
rock
but it does kind of have some like green
on top of it
yeah good catch
good catch I'm not sure who who caught
that initially
oh and chat at all or if I did if he did
Bo and sorry I missed it Bowen just
dropping in to say sitting definitely is
in this game
there you go guys
such a funny question
such a funny question
if they tweet out tomorrow sitting
I will lose my mind you guys imagine
upgrades imagine yeah and those those
upgrades will make it feel better the
broom you can only fly
um you can only go at Max Speed it's
kind of like a turbo
okay
also up here at the 14-minute stay to
play oh my gosh
I trust you
rubber duck 77 Wizarding World Fan
theories you just take this Canon for me
it's that crook Shanks is The Potter's
cat mentioned in the letter from Lily to
sirius oh my gosh
I don't know if I've heard that one
before
everyone
sitting in Hogwarts Legacy
can you confirm
you're a wizard uh Kelly I don't know if
it's been mentioned yet when they are
exploring the Little Village area
there's a door with a lock that needs
unlocked yes yes yes it looks like the
alohomora
Aloha Mora sorry people always jump on
me for that one alohomora alohomora
Hermione would be getting getting onto
me
oh let's see I don't know
oh yeah that's the one I just read Marco
can't help to wonder what the post game
is going to look like they will put new
game plus I hope so Marco I hope New
Game Plus feels like it's pretty much a
standard now for open World Games
they'll definitely be
I mean you're definitely going to be
able to roam the world and explore right
even if they reset you before the final
mission however they choose to handle it
I just hope I just hope there's a lot of
stuff to do right
I mean I've I've said I feel like it'll
be like a 20-hour game maybe 30 40 to do
everything but I would love to be blown
away and it's like a 50 60 70 hour to to
see and do everything you know
I would love that and when you think
about the castle alone
and that's kind of what Alan was talking
about there how it amazes him that you
can do all that in the open world and
then you just fly up to the castle and
he he knows that like the professors are
there and some students are there
and you could like all that's happening
as you fly away it's awesome
awesome
sitting in the water
oh geez
make the hashtag can we sit
oh my goodness during night I think
we'll be able to pass time by sleeping
yeah I feel like there'll have to be
some because Alan touched on the fact
that there's going to be certain items
that you can only find at night which
makes me think there's going to be
certain quests as well
Johnny sees 60 hours unless you just
Speed play then see 20 20 or more
all right so guys this is not our last
stream of the week
this is not our last stream of the week
we have our Christmas celebration stream
coming up this Friday
I hope as many of you as possible can
make it it is going to be at 8pm Eastern
lots of giveaways we talked earlier if
you haven't seen what the giveaways are
I posted it on the Community page and
also here also on Twitter
um but the big thing is we're giving
away three copies of the Hogwarts Legacy
deluxe edition digital
on the platform of your choice so you
get to pick the platform
so this is just a small way for me to
get back for the amazing year that you
guys have uh
have helped make happen here in this
community and you know it's kind of a
it's kind of a big turning point right
we're
it's a new chapter once this game comes
out things will be different things will
change
so we gotta celebrate we gotta
gotta have a good time so as many of you
as possible hope to see you there if you
can't make it the VOD will be up
unfortunately you do you do have to be
present to win
but um the VOD will stay up for anybody
who wants to to check that out later
[Music]
sitting confirmed right there
sitting confirmed right there from
Pastor Professor Baxter
we've already seen it in cut scenes
there you go
right here before we end rubber duck
with a subscription thank you rubber
duck and then volte jumping in with a
super chat oh see how's it been hey man
can't stay long on the phone I have to
do a rape replay Squad just wanted to
send some love volte appreciate all the
love and support thank you for the Super
Chat it's been a it's been a roller
coaster stream I'll tell you that I
thought we were gonna have time to go
through the full showcase we only made
it through the first like open world
flight section but it was a great uh it
was a great Deep dive I'll tell you that
a great Deep dive looking at everything
trying to find all the little details so
all right
yes Draco try to be there always enjoy
the live streams lumos to those who
can't make it
did it and tagged everyone
I can't always sit oh my gosh
oh my goodness uh that's actually a good
question Timothy so any item in my shop
any so for the merch stuff I'll give
away three three separate giveaways you
could pick any item in my shop any
single item same for James's shop
so expecto goes gonna donate a merch
item as well you can pick anything in in
their shop
[Music]
makes make sit half it oh my God you
gotta gotta be careful about that one
don't slip an extra H in there
Chandler be like what excuse me
what are they what are they telling me
they want in the game
Jason I have confirmed running and
standing
Christy did hashtag can't we sit
[Music]
yeah Rodrigo that some people were
making that comment a while ago on
Twitter like what's the point of having
that if you can't
if you can't sit oh when I knew exactly
what I was doing
for sure for sure all right guys this
has been fun thanks thanks to everyone
for hanging out we'll be back on Friday
hope to see you all there it'll be a
shorter Stream So I know you guys got
family family time most likely
um some of you may be traveling so it'll
be a shorter stream we'll get we'll get
right into the giveaway so hope to see
you all there
um make sure you subscribe if you're not
already subscribed you do have to be
subscribed to win uh because you have to
be able to subscribe you have to chat to
be able to win this stuff and to be able
to chat you have to be subscribed to the
channel
um so make sure you subscribed but yeah
guys thank you all so much hope
everybody has a fantastic rest of your
week stay warm stay healthy crazy lots
of sickness going on right now uh and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
I'll talk to you again soon
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]